Members elect, in your seat pockets is an oath of office slip.
If somebody else, if there is not a slip in your seat pocket in front of you, please check underneath your seat because that is where your oath slip may likely be.
If none is there, then somebody took it by accident.
So please make sure that you read the oath slips.
Do not sign said oath slips until I direct you to later.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Спасибо.
Members, take your seats.
Thank you.
Members, please take your seats.
.
and F2L should be back there and the other side of the street should be over there.
But they're, the case for whatever time is there, the other side of the street.
That's where all they are.
They're all the good.
That's why.
Members will be in their seats.
Members, please pay attention.
In your seat pockets.
Now, I want to explain the seat pockets.
If you were seated in the middle of a row or in Division I and V, the end of a row, your seat pockets may be under your seat.
So if the sheet in front of you in the box does not have your name on it, please check underneath your seat.
Do not sign the oath of office until instructed to do so after you have taken the oath of office.
If you have already done that, don't worry, I won't fire you.
If you do not have an oath slip, that means a neighbor took it.
So please share.
Make sure that you have the right one.
They were all individually put in yesterday afternoon, and I was here at 7 o'clock last night putting these out, so I know that none of them moved.
Thank you.
Hear ye!
This day, December 7, 2022, the first Wednesday of December, being the day designated by the Constitution, Part 2, Article 3, for assembling of the body, the 168th General Court of the State of New Hampshire at the capital in the city of Concord, I do hereby convene to order the 2023 House of Representatives.
The members elect will rise and be reverently attentive while Reverend Peggy Schnack, the curate of St.
Paul's Episcopal Church and Concord, leads us in prayer.
I invite you to close your eyes, bow your heads in whatever prayer position you prefer.
Let us pray.
Creator God, source of all being.
We know that we live in a world that is so often filled with division and mistrust in our communities and our government.
We also know that it does not have to be that way.
Help those gathered here today to serve with integrity, to have open minds and hearts so that they may faithfully serve those who have entrusted them with the responsibility to be their voices in our government.
Give them the grace not only to hear, but truly listen to one another and the people of the state of New Hampshire.
Grant them the wisdom to work together and put aside individual ambition so that they may enact such laws as to bring unity around the causes of justice, peace, and respect for the dignity of every human being.
I ask your blessings to come upon all who are gathered here so that they may feel a presence beyond themselves that will sustain and guide them in times of conflict, uncertainty, and doubt, as well as in times of joy.
Amen.
Please remain standing while Representative-elect Valerie MacDonald from Salem leads us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
The Pledge of Allegiance is the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Please remain standing while the Franklin High School Choir sings our national anthem.
Thank you.
Oh, say can you see, by the dawn's early light, What so proudly we hailed at the twilight's last gleaming, Whose broad stripes and bright stars through the perilous fight, O'er the ramparts we watched were so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare, the bombs bursting in air, Gave proof to the night that our flag was still there.
Oh, say does that star-spangled banner yet wave for the land of the free and the home of the brave.
Thank you.
The House will attend to requests for leaves of absence.
Mr.
Speaker, the day, illness, representatives Hacken Phillips, O'Hara, Juliet Smith, the day, important business, representatives Cody, Stringham, and Vincent.
These leaves of absence shall be granted unless otherwise ordered by the House.
The House will attend to the long introduction of guests.
Mr.
Speaker, please welcome Rosemary Orr, wife of Representative-elect Orr.
Anthony Henry, guest of Representative-elect Leon.
Mary Myers, guest of Representative-elect Howard.
Diane Myler, wife of Representative-elect Myler.
Caleb Labby, guest of Representative-elect Yokela.
Michael Aaron, husband of Representative-elect Aaron.
Paul Barton, husband of Representative-elect Seabert.
Jason Talurski and Dorothy Newell, husband and grandmother of Representative-elect Talurski.
John L.
James Jackson, Jamila Ashanti Scales, and Gloria Timmons, grandchildren and guest of Representative-elect Harriet Gathright.
Julie Miles, guest of Representative-elect McGew.
Debbie and Holly Darby, wife and daughter of Representative-elect Darby.
Grace Kennedy, wife of Representative-elect Kennedy.
Sophia Biondelillo, daughter of Representative-elect Bolden.
Emily Sousi and Lilium Delmasto, daughter and granddaughter of Representative-elect Sousi, Jonathan Forelli and Master Sergeant Christopher Brown, New Hampshire Air National Guard, sons of Representative-elect Carol Brown, Valerie Hill, mother of Representative-elect Hill, Leslie, Lara, Dylan, and Henry Germana, wife and children of Representative-elect Germana.
Elizabeth, David, and Heather Thomas, and Kim Terrigny, wife, children, and sister-in-law of Representative-elect Doug Thomas.
Meredith Burnham, daughter of Representative-elect Burnham.
Melody Smith, guest of Representative-elect Notting-Wong.
Dennis, Deborah, Joseph, and Ava Tensar, parents and children of Representative-elect Tensar.
Mary and Lydia Petternell, Mary Beth Wadlinger, Catherine Collins, Robin Doherty, Wendy, and Ginger Platch, and Sharon and Mac Carpenter, guests of Representative-elect Petternell.
Christina King, wife of Representative-elect Seth King.
Michael Granger, father of Representative-elect Granger.
Brian Major, Joan Lanois, Wendy and Larkin Sanford, husband, mother, sister, and niece of Representative-elect Major.
Thomas Opel, guest of Representative-elect Morse.
Peter Walsh, guest of Representative-elect Stavis.
Jeanine Safin and Steve Grill, parents of Representative-elect Grill.
John Perez, husband of Representative-elect Perez.
Brian and Pauline McDonnell, parents of Representative-elect McDonnell.
Mark Colcombe, husband of Representative-elect Colcombe.
Helen, Ace, and Faith Weary, wife and daughters of Representative-elect Weary.
David and Debbie Herndon, Maddie, Greg, Ethan Herndon, Emma Gregg, parents, husband, and children of Representative-elect Gregg, James Ravan, husband of Representative-elect Elberger, Virginia Dry, daughter of Representative-elect Dry, Jill Duncan, Chelsea Lemke, and Haley, Riley, and Josephine Coker, mother-in-law, wife, and daughters of Representative-elect Coker, Todd Selig, husband of Representative-elect Selig.
Patricia Bogert, wife of Representative-elect Bogert.
Cara Dunn, wife of Representative-elect Dunn.
Emerald Anderson Ford, wife of Representative-elect Ford.
Joseph Lanza, husband of Representative-elect Lanza.
Allison Hicks, wife of Representative-elect Hicks.
Colby Ouellette, wife of Representative Ouellette.
Michael Reed and Elizabeth Kirby, husband and guest of Representative-elect Reed.
Carrie Kin, Rachel Ahern, and Deborah DeWitt, guest of Representative-elect William Dolan.
Joyce Weston, guest of Representative-elect Lovett.
Jacob and Natalie Sellers, Meredith Page and Donna Johnson-Page Sellers.
Brian Lewis, grandchildren, stepdaughter, wife, and guest of Representative-elect Sellers, James Weber, partner of Representative-elect Priest, Paul Matthews and Marshall Carey Matthews, husband and son of Representative-elect Carey, Ed Staub, husband of Representative-elect Staub, David G., David W., and Garrett Hebert, husband and sons of Representative-elect Hebert, Robert LeClaire and Seamus Doherty, husband and grandson of Representative-elect Heath.
Mark Nozzle and Pat Teton, husband and guest of Representative-elect Wendy Thomas.
James Corliss, father-in-law of Representative-elect Nutting.
Gary and Jeff Hamer, husband and son of Representative-elect Hamer.
Catherine Turrer and Elizabeth McConnell, wife and guest of Representative-elect Turrerrer.
Daniel Mills, husband of Representative-Elect Spear.
Mark Quaratiello, guest of Representative-Elect Quaratiello.
Rita Mattson, guest of Representative-Elect Rhodes.
Bruce and Joanne Wilhelm, parents of Representative-Elect Wilhelm.
Verde Packard, sister of Representative-Elect Packard.
The Honorable Patricia Klee, former member from Nashua, guest of Representative Elects Vail and Dutsey, the Honorable Dick Marston, former member from Manchester, guest of Representative Elect Infantine.
They are with us in the gallery today.
Welcome to the New Hampshire House.
Gracias.
Good morning, members elect.
Welcome to the 168th session of the general court.
You have been chosen by the citizens of this state for a noble purpose.
We are experiencing one of the closest divisions ever known in this chamber, and it is my fervent hope that this chamber will rise to that occasion.
The seating for today was done purposely.
Granted it has been done this way in the past, distantly, but it is done for a convenience.
It is done because we will be voting at various voting boxes, and historically, the names are mismatched, and people cross and trip over each other during the voting process, and we're trying to avoid that.
So, over in Division 1 and ending in Division 5 we have our A's through Z's.
So when the time comes for the voting procedures you will attend at the various boxes.
There's one up front here, one up front in the back, one up front in the back over here, and one down here.
We will now begin the process of the calling of the roll.
The members elect are requested to remain in their seats and answer in firm voices.
Members elect who do not answer will not be recorded as having been present and therefore will not be recorded as having taken the oath of office to be administered by the governor directly following this calling of the roll.
So members, please be in your seats at this time.
This call will be taken alphabetically by county.
By county.
So if you're a Smith in Sullivan County, do not answer Smith for Belknap County.
We will begin with Belknap County.
Bean.
Beaudoin.
Bogert.
Bords.
Coker.
Comtois.
Dumais.
Harvey Beaulieu.
Here.
Heards.
Coker.
Here.
Comtois.
Dumais.
Yes.
Harvey Beaulia.
Here.
Hewitt.
McCarter.
Here.
Nagel.
O'Hara.
Travis O'Hara.
Ploge.
Present.
Smart.
Here.
St.
Clair.
Here.
Terry.
Present.
Trottier.
Here.
St.
Clair.
Terry.
Trottier.
Varney.
Carroll County.
Avalani.
Belcher.
Brown.
Bucco.
Burroughs, Cordelli, Costable, Crawford, McDonald, McAleer, McConkie, Page, Petternel, Smith, Woodcock, Here.
Cheshire County.
Abbott.
Here.
Ames.
Eaton.
Here.
Faulkner, Filio, Fox, Germana, Harvey, Hunt, Jones, Montiel, Newell, Jody Newell Nutting Partial Qualey Rhodes Santanastazo Shapiro Tatro Thaxton Toll Weber Coas County, Cascaden, Davis, Hatch, William Hatch, Kelly, King, Myrner, Noel, Willett, Tierney, Grafton County, Adjutant, Almy, Baldwin, Berejni, Bolton, Brown, Corman, Kulon, Fellows, Greeson, Hawken Phillips, Phillips, Hoyt, Ladd, Lovett, Massimilla, Morse, Muirhead, Murphy, Nordgren, Rochefort, Sellers, Simon, Stavis, Stringham, Stringham.
Sullivan.
Here.
Sykes.
Hillsborough County, Hebert, Alexander, Ammon, Barudi, Bolio, Berry, Boh Here, here, Bouchard.
Here, Bolden.
Here, Boyd.
Bradley.
Here, here, Calabro.
Here, here, Cretien.
Here, here, Cocolm.
Here, Cole.
Here, here, Corcoran.
Here, Cornell.
Here, here, Cody.
Cody.
Crayton.
Here, here, Cushman Cushman Darby Davis Devine De Silvestro Dolan Dutsey Elberger earth Erf, Fadolfi, Ford, Fox, Lauren Fox, Freitas, Gagney, Goalie, Gorski, Gould, Greg, Griffin, Grill, Hamer, Harriet Gathright, Healy, Heath, Herbert, Howard, Hines, Infantine, Jack, Jack.
Here.
Judy.
Jean Judy.
Oh.
Juris.
Here.
Kelly.
Kennedy.
Here.
Kenny.
King.
Here.
Cofalt.
Lanza.
Lascellus, here, Lawton, Lawton, Leapley, here, Leclerc, here, Leishman, here, Alicia Lekas, here, Tony Lekas, here, Lewicki, here, Lloyd, here, Long, here, McKenzie, here, Manjaputi.
Here Ming.
Mooney.
Morton.
Moulton.
Murphy.
Alessandra Murray.
Megan Murray.
Ray Newman.
Sue Newman.
Noble.
Nauter.
Sue Newman.
Here.
Noble.
Notter.
Here, Mr.
Clark.
Thank you.
Nutter Upham.
Here.
Nutting Wong.
Nutting Wong, here.
Thank you, Representative.
O'Brien Panic.
Panic.
Power.
Peterson.
Perez.
The one in Hillsboro County.
Thank you.
Patrigno.
Here.
Plett.
Here, Mr.
Clerk.
Thank you.
Post.
Here.
Priest.
Prue.
Here.
Prout.
Raymond.
Here.
Reed.
Renzullo.
Here.
Rombo.
Rung.
Here.
Ryan.
Ryan, Sanborn, Seibert, Seidel, Sheehan, Sirwa, Sirway, Juliet Smith, Juliet Smith.
Sophokitis.
Spear.
Starr.
Juliet Smith.
Sophocitas.
Spear.
Staub.
Talersky.
Tellez.
Tenzar.
Thomas.
Ulery.
Vail.
Veyu.
Wheeler.
Werry, Wilhelm, Merrimack County, Andrews, Ores, Aylward, Boyd, Stephen Boyd, Here.
Brennan.
Here.
Cambrils.
Kaplan.
Here.
Boyd, Stephen Boyd, Brennan, Cambrils, Kaplan, Carey, Ebel, Ellison, Gallagher, Gerhard, Gibbs, Gould, Hall, Hicks, Hill, Hole, Lane, Levitt, Luno, McKay, Mason, James Mason, Dan McGuire, Carol McGuire, McWilliams, Moffett, Moffett, Myler, Payor, Palazzov, Richards, Here.
Reisner.
Here.
Schamberg.
Schuett.
Here.
Schuett, Schultz, Seaworth, See, Shurtleff, Susie, Testerman, Turcotte, Alan Turcotte, Thank you.
Walner.
Here.
Walsh.
Wolf.
Here.
Alan Turcott thank you Walner Walsh Wolf Wood Rockingham County Balboni ball Bartlett Bernard, Brouillard, Here, Michael Cahill, Here, Tim Cahill, Here, DeSimone, DeLorenzo, Here, Dolan, Here, Donnelly, Here, Doucette, Here, Drago, Here, Dunn, Here, Edgar.
Brothers.
Edwards.
Here.
Emmerich.
Foote.
Here.
Ford.
Gilman.
Here.
Grossman.
Grota.
Here.
Guthrie.
Hamblett Harb Harley Haskins, Hobson, Janvron, Katzikoros, Phyllis Katzikoros.
Thank you.
Muse.
Mills.
Munns.
Murray.
Nelson.
O'Neill.
Osborne.
Jason Osborne.
Packard.
Page.
Mark Pearson.
Steven Pearson Perez Phillips Piemonte, Popovici-Muller, Porcelli, Patucic, Patucic Present Pratt Present Prudhomme O'Brien Here Quartiello Here Reynolds Here Reed Here Roy Pratt, Prudhomme O'Brien, Coratiello, Reynolds, Reed, Roy, Simpson, Sody, Spillane, Summers, Sweeney, Here.
SciTech.
Here.
Thomas.
Trip.
Here.
True.
Present.
Tudor.
Here.
Turrer.
Cytec, Thomas, Trip, True, Tudor, Turrer, Valoon, Vandy Castile, Verville, Vought, Vose, Wallace, Walsh, Ward, Wyler, Yokela, Stratford County, Ankerberg, Bailey, Bay, Bickford, David Bickford.
Bixby.
Burnham.
Cannon.
Conlon.
Connor.
Fitzpatrick.
Granger.
Harrington.
Horgan.
Horrigan.
Howard.
Howland, Kaczynski, Kenny, Lamontagne, Levesque, Here.
Munir.
Here.
Newton.
Clifford Newton.
Here.
Pear.
Present.
Finney.
Here.
Petrie.
Clifford Newton, Pear, Finney, Petrie, Potenza, Cecilia Rich, Jeffrey Rich, Schmidt, Selig, Jeff Smith Marjorie Smith Southworth Trelevin, Turcotte, Vincent, Wall, Sullivan County, Aaron, Cloutier, Damon, Dry, Merchant, Palmer, Rollins, Smith, Spillsbury, Here.
Stapleton.
Here.
Stone.
Sullivan.
Here.
Tanner.
Spillsbury, here.
Stapleton, here.
Stone, here.
Sullivan, here.
Tanner, here.
At this time, we will coordinate and figure out the numbers and have a return for you shortly.
If any members came into the hall after I called the roll and your name was missed.
Please come forward now.
Thank you.
Gracias.
I don't know.
Okay.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Gracias.谢谢大家 .
.
391 members elect having answered the call, a quorum is present.
The chair, on behalf of the House of Representatives, will now appoint a committee to wait upon the Governor and Executive Council to inform them that a quorum of the House is assembled and requests their attendance.
In keeping with tradition, the Chair appoints the new Dean of the House, the member from Concord serving her 22nd term, Representative-elect Mary Jane Wallner.
From the town of Ridge, serving his 19th term, Representative-elect John Hunt.
From the town of Derry, serving her 19th term, Representative-elect Phyllis Katsikouris.
And from the town of Madbury, Representative-elect Janet Wall, who is also serving her 19th term.
If there are any other members that at this time did not answer the call that have entered the chamber, please come down front at this time.
Gracias.
The committee is excused.
For those of you who are in your second term, welcome to Organization Day in the New Hampshire House Chamber.
At this time what will happen is the governor and council will make their way to the chamber.
The sergeant-at-arms will introduce the executive council who will join me on the rostrum.
Then the sergeant-at-arms will introduce His Excellency, the governor, who will proceed to swear you in.
At that time you should follow along with your oath slips that are in your seat pockets.
you have taken the oath, just a reminder, when the Executive Council and the Governor are introduced, we should stand and greet them as according.
By the way, if we haven't discussed this already, turn them to silent, please.
If I hear one, I will know where it's coming from.
I will look at you, and that is an automatic $25 donation to the New Hampshire Food Bank.
Thank you.
Gracias.
The chair recognizes the chair of the board.
The chair recognizes the sergeant at arms.
Mr.
Chair, the honorable executive counsel.
Council.
The chair recognizes the sergeant at arms.
Mr.
Chair, the governor, His Excellency Christopher T.
Sununu.
P.
Please remain standing.
In your seat pockets as previously discussed you will find an affirmation or oath statement in your seat pocket.
After the swearing in, please sign it where indicated and pass it to the right for collection by a member of the staff.
Please remain standing while the governor administers the oath of office.
Good morning.
Together again.
This is great.
This is absolutely terrific.
Last year, or two years ago, when we had the swearing-in ceremony, as a lot of you remember, and for those who are new might not have been there, we were out in about 20-degree weather out on the field at UNH.
Thank you.
or two years ago when we had the swearing-in ceremony, as a lot of you remember, and for those who are new might not have been there, we were out in about 20-degree weather out on the field at UNH dealing with the COVID crisis and all of that.
But, you know, whether it's working with Republicans or working with Democrats or dealing through a pandemic, this body gets it done.
One way or the other, they always find a way to get it done.
And I think there's a huge lesson in that, right, not just for New Hampshire, but really for the rest of the country, that it isn't about partisanship and bickering.
We have our heated arguments, of course, that's what we're here to do.
We're here to fight out our positions and represent our constituents.
But in New Hampshire, we always find a way to get it done.
And to be back in this chamber, one of the most historic chambers in the country, is really, really awesome, especially for what we're doing today in terms of bringing in 400 new members.
399?
399 new members.
We've still got a tie.
We're going to work that one out.
To have 399 new members.
So if you will all follow me, first please raise your right hand and repeat after me.
I state your name.
Of.
Do solemnly swear.
That I will bear faith in true allegiance.
To the United States of America.
And the state of New Hampshire.
And will support the constitutions thereof.
So help me God.
I, state your name.
Do solemnly and sincerely.
Swear and affirm.
That I will faithfully and impartially.
Discharge and perform.
All the duties incumbent upon me as state representative according to the best of my abilities agreeably to the rules and regulations of this Constitution and the laws of the state of New Hampshire.
So help me God.
Congratulations.
Good luck everybody.
All right, all right.
Have him come up here.
You're going to need to print out a couple of hooks.
So this man is going to print one out for you.
Watch out for you.
This is a little bit.
I don't know.
No, I think it's a little bit.
Print print.
Print print print.
Ladies and gentlemen, if you had any issues with the oath sheet, please come down to my left, your right, immediately.
Thank you.
The House Clerk's Office staff will now come and please pass your oath slips to your right.
And my staff will come and collect, except for those of you in Division 1.
Right?
No, that's right.
Yes.
Pass to your right.
Thank you.
I'm not in the position.
Do the three judges have to sign it?
Yes, sir.
Thank you very much.
You want it in the quaker?
Yes, sir.
Let's go back to you.
I'll call it.
Thank you.
It's good to be back.
Well, ladies and gentlemen, congratulations.
We just have a couple of technical issues to fix up here quickly, and we will be right with you.
But we will get right into the election of speaker.
The ground rules for that election were printed in your calendar.
If you have any questions about that, you're welcome to ask.
But just if you could be patient for a couple of minutes while we get our oaths resolved.
Thank you.
How are you?
Representative Kelly, Eamon Kelly, are you all set?
You finally, it was under your, did you get it though?
I need you, come on up.
I would like to thank Representative Thaxton for donating $25 to the New Hampshire Food Bank for his cell phone going off.
I mean, that whole thing is demon.
Tell you what the one with an EY.
Is it, is it early?
It's like the whole time.
I just like going to the whole time.
Thank you.
You guys are great.
Thank you so much.
Gracias.
Thank you.
The House will come to order.
The chair has proposed ground rules for election which have been reviewed by the candidates for speaker and has been printed in the House calendar.
Representatives Packard and Wilhelm move the adoption of the ground rules for the election.
The question is on the adoption of the rules for election.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
All those opposed nay.
The ayes have have it and the rules for election have been adopted Nominations for the office of Speaker of the House are in order.
The chair recognizes the member from Concord, Representative Mary Jane Walner, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
And good morning and congratulations to all the members of the New Hampshire House.
Today is an auspicious day for all of us.
For the first time in two years, we are beginning our term, return to this hallowed chamber.
Two years ago, we were opening the session outdoors in a field hockey field, and it was 20 degrees.
Inaugurably, the position of our nation and our chamber on that day in 2020 was historic, in the throes of an unprecedented global pandemic and a starkly polarized political climate.
Today in 2022, our country and our state are just as divided and the makeup of this chamber is equally as historic.
We sit here today with the closest chamber party makeup in the history of the New Hampshire House and potentially the best opportunity for us to work together.
The best opportunity in our history for us to work together.
That is why I rise today to nominate Representative Matt Wilhelm for Speaker of the House.
For those that don't know me, I am entering my 22nd term in the New Hampshire House.
I have served many of my over 40 years in the House in both committee leadership and as rank-and-file member.
It's true, every term presents new challenges for a legislature of this size.
I have served in the House under 15 speakers, each of them differently gifted as they took on the considerable responsibility of leading this body.
And what a considerable responsibility it is.
I have learned that a good speaker is someone who can be both bold and kind, not afraid to call out issues of decorum, but compassionate enough to care that every member's concerns are heard.
A good speaker, like a good representative, must have a humble servant's heart.
A good speaker must put democracy and the institution before themselves, before ego, before personality, or political motive.
When you meet Matt, it is clear that he possesses all of these traits and is ideally poised to assume responsibility for our state's biggest challenges, as well as those we face within these historic walls of Representative Hall.
When you work with Matt, you can be confident that he deeply cares.
Coming from a background of service work, he speaks with principled conviction about the duty we hold to serve one another, to serve our state, and to serve our country.
Matt knows innately how to negotiate difficult conversations, leaving everyone feeling understood.
He puts state before self and institution before ego.
Matt is wise enough to know when to ask for help and input.
He seeks out guidance and as a speaker will devote himself to learning what he doesn't know.
Matt wakes up thinking about how to better the institution and goes to bed considering the advice he heard throughout the day.
That's leadership.
That's a good speaker.
After four decades in this job and too many session days to count in this room, I can say that I am fully confident that Matt embodies the right recipe of integrity, empathy, idealism necessary to join the ranks of esteemed leaders before him.
Instead of yielding to growing extremism and partisanship, we right now have the opportunity to elevate a new generation of leadership and bridge the divide we have for too long seen among us.
With this in mind, I am honored to ask that you join me in electing Matt Wilhelm for Speaker of the New Hampshire House.
Thank you.
Representative Mary Jane Walner places the name of Representative Matthew Wilhelm in nomination for speaker.
The chair recognizes the member from Kentuckuk, my rep, Representative Mel Myler for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Colleagues, I rise today to second the nomination of Matt Wilhelm, who is Speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives.
The Speaker of the House must represent all of us, regardless of our political party.
The position of Speaker is neither Republican nor Democrat.
This hallowed Assembly needs a leader who is open to diverse opinions and fosters respect for civil discourse to finding the common ground resolution of complex issues.
Leadership depends someone who will listen, who will learn, who will act, with respect for the individuals regardless of their partisan position.
Matt Wilhelm is that leader.
He has a history of serving communities of multiple interests.
After graduating from Plymouth State, Matt moved to Manchester, where he served as an AmeriCorps team leader for City Year New Hampshire.
chargedged with the uniting America using uniting Americans from diverse backgrounds and walks of life, Matt led his peers through a challenging year of full-time volunteer service in some of the state's most highest need and underserved schools.
He is committed to building a community of common interests, representing the common good of New Hampshire citizens.
He clearly is a servant leader, one who focuses on the needs of others than his own.
Matt earned his master's degree in public administration at the University of New Hampshire.
He built a career in the nonprofit sector, leading nonpartisan teams to identify community challenges, solving problems, and getting things done.
He has stepped up during this period of hyper-partisanship to lead this body in building consensus, embracing innovation, and delivering results for all Granite Staters.
Back in his first term, Matt introduced and passed a bipartisan piece of legislation, establishing a commission to study the workforce patterns of national service alumni so that they can be more service-driven and community- minded young people so that they can pursue a degree or a credential providing meaningful citizenship in the Granite State.
Matt went on to chair this Commission and during the 1919 and 2020 session and we will be considering some of the issues that came out of that commission in this session.
Colleagues, no member of this body should ever feel intimidated or sanctioned because of your position on an issue or a vote before this assembly.
It is the speaker's responsibility to create a culture of inclusion and tolerance for diverse opinions.
It is time for a change.
If you want a speaker that will respect you and your opinions, a speaker that will seek your input, a speaker that will have an open door to your ideas, a speaker who cares for the integrity of the process of this House.
If these are the issues that are important to you, then I encourage you to support and vote for Matt Wilhelm, Speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives.
Thank you, my colleagues and Mr.
Clerk.
Representative Mel Myler seconds the nomination of Representative Matthew Wilhelm for Speaker.
The chair recognizes the member from Manchester, Representative Matthew Wilhelm.
It is with great respect for this historic chamber and institution that I humbly accept this nomination for Speaker of the House.
Like many of you, or your children or grandchildren, nieces and nephews, I first came to the House as a fourth grader up in the gallery.
We really won the jackpot because house was in session that day.
I remember how it feels.
I remember how warm it was.
It was a late May afternoon.
I remember looking down and thinking to myself, it'd be pretty cool to serve here one day.
It's no secret that we're coming off a challenging term here in the House.
You either lived through it yourself or you were recruited to run because someone else had had enough or because you thought you could do a better job than the person in the seat before you.
Colleagues whether you're a Republican or a Democrat, whether you were sworn in today for the first time, the 22nd time, or somewhere in between.
Granite Staters are counting on us, all of us, to reject trench warfare and ideological battles and instead come together and work together to deliver results for our neighbors.
We can do better and we must do better and with this chamber tied, nearly tied, between the minority and the majority, we have to be open to new approaches, new ideas, and new leadership to meet this moment.
And that's why I'm asking for your vote today for Speaker of the House.
So while there may not be a Democratic mandate or a Republican mandate heading into this term, there is a uniquely granite state mandate to roll up our sleeves and work together to deal with some big issues.
challenges that previous legislatures have struggled to tackle, but that continue to get worse for families in my district and yours, kitchen table issues like the high cost of energy, housing, child care, and more.
Over the last several weeks, I've been sharing a series of proposals aimed at promoting unity and bipartisan cooperation, which I've also shared with my opponent in this race.
These proposals aim to curate a more productive work environment for all legislators, regardless of party affiliation.
And I want to share some of those ideas with you today.
First, as Speaker, I will assign an even number of Democrats and Republicans to all 20 standing committees.
Minority party committee assignments will be made not just with the advice but the consent of the minority leader.
Where it's possible and it makes sense I will appoint Republican chairs and Democratic vice chair pairings as well as some Democratic chairs and Republican vice chair pairings.
As Speaker I will also ensure the total number of statutory and study committee assignments are balanced between the majority and the minority and that the total membership of the House Rules Committee and major statutory committees fiscal, JLCAR facilities are evenly balanced as well.
Additionally, I will ensure that both the majority and the minority receive appointments to all committees of conference and can be removed with the concurrence of their respective leader.
As Speaker, I will create a bipartisan state budget process ruling amendments that add unrelated policy issues to the state budget as non-germain.
As Speaker, I will ensure transparency in our scheduling, providing significant notice prior to upcoming session days and prioritizing consistency in committee meeting schedules.
As Speaker, I will also support a House rule authorizing members who are absent due to medical condition, illness, or illness in the family to cast votes through a proxy in full House sessions.
We have members absent today who tested positive earlier this week for COVID-19.
Other members may feel pressure this to roll up even when they're sick because the numbers are just that close.
Let's prioritize the health and safety of one another and our families.
It's simply the right thing to do.
As Speaker, I will work with both caucuses to provide an opportunity for mixed seating in Division 3.
Based on demand, we'll seat a limited number of Republicans and Democrats side by side in hopes of providing space that members can deepen relationships and build bridges across party lines.
I also want to put my experience in nonpartisan nonprofit administration to work by building on next week's Braver Angels workshop and introducing a new tradition to the Chamber, the Martin Luther King Jr.
Day of Service.
As Speaker, I will establish a bipartisan special committee, in fact two of them, to tackle the biggest challenges facing our state.
First, we'll establish a special committee on housing.
Our businesses need workers and our workforce need a place to live.
We will get this done in the new year.
I also want to create a special committee on childcare.
The availability of quality, affordable, safe, and reliable childcare is critical for parents, especially women who are more likely than men to quit their job during the pandemic, to either return to or remain in the workforce.
We can do hard things when we work together, and New Hampshire families are counting on us to do just that.
When we do, I am confident that it will prove to be not only good policymaking, but good politics.
Colleagues, we have an opportunity to meet this moment and bring back balance to the New Hampshire House, but to do so, we must summon the courage to try something new.
As a fourth grader, I looked down from the House gallery and wondered if one day I might have the opportunity to serve my community in this historic chamber.
Thirty years later, I stand before you as a candidate for speaker, asking you to believe in our collective power, to turn the page, and to begin writing a new chapter together.
Regardless of party, I humbly ask for your vote today.
Thank you Representative Wilhelm accepts the nomination further nominations are in order the chair recognizes the member from Londonderry representative Wayne McDonald for the purpose of making a nomination Thank Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Colleagues and fellow citizens, I have the high honor and the great privilege to rise today to nominate Sherman Packard for Speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives.
I have known Sherm for over 30 years.
I have known him as a good friend, fellow citizen of Londonderry, and most relevant to our gathering here today, a veteran member of this body.
Sherm was first elected to the House in in 1990 and was recently re-elected to his 17th term.
This speaks volumes as to his commitment to this institution, its procedures, its mission, and his love for the people of our great state.
He has sponsored many good pieces of legislation during his time here and has served as the chairman of committees, deputy minority leader, as minority leader, as speaker pro tem, deputy speaker, and as we all know for these past two years, speaker.
I believe that it's important as we discuss this important office today, we remember Sherm did not originally set out to be Speaker when we met in an athletic field at UNH two years ago.
On that bright, sunny, and cold day, he planned to serve as deputy speaker in the administration of his good friend, Representative Dick Hinch of Merrimack.
We elected Dick speaker that day, and we all looked forward to a productive term.
As we remember all too well, things tragically changed very unexpectedly just one week later with Speaker Hinch's passing.
As if the challenges of the pandemic and the need to get the business of the House done weren't challenging enough in a partnership with Speaker Hinch, Sherm was now suddenly thrust into the role of acting speaker.
No one could have been better prepared to assume the responsibilities of the office at such a challenging time.
His many years of experience were clearly demonstrated.
He ably led us through the next several weeks to Constitution Day on January 6, 2021, when he was elected speaker for the upcoming term.
Speaker Packard, the House leadership team, and the House staff proceeded to get the people's business done.
Realizing the pandemic and the state of emergency we were operating under at the time prevented us from meeting in this chamber, alternate sites were found where social distancing and other health precautions could be taken.
Committees met in hybrid fashion, and all House deadlines were kept.
Eventually, things got back to normal.
Colleagues, I realize that there are members of two great political parties gathered here in this chamber today, each with their own noble beliefs, principles, traditions, and objectives.
There is much for us to disagree about, and that will be demonstrated many times in these next two years.
However, I hope we will always be proud of what our two parties did on September 15th of this year.
We came together in the true spirit of compromise and bipartisanship, suspended the House rules, and passed legislation to help income-eligible families make it through this current heating season.
The legislation wasn't perfect.!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
It's something that Democrats and their leadership can be proud of and made happen.
It's something that Republicans can be proud of and our leadership made happen.
Colleagues, I ask that you re-elect Sherman Packard, Speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives.
Thank you very much.
Representative Wayne McDonald places the name of Representative Sherman Packard in nomination for speaker.
The chair recognizes the member from Wilton, Representative Jim Kofalt, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
I think my good colleague from Londonderry covered pretty much everything I would want to say.
This body has been fairly closely divided over the past two years, as it's much more closely divided for the coming two years.
I think that this is a time to have somebody who can bring people together in a spirit of cooperation and collaboration and effective leadership.
So I will keep my comments brief and simply say that I would ask you to support Sherm Packard as our speaker for the next two years and I would like to formally second his nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Representative Jim Cofalt seconds the nomination of Representative Sherman Packard.
The chair recognizes the member from Bedford.
Representative Lori Sanborn for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Good morning.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thanks to all of you for being here for today and for choosing to serve.
I rise to second the nomination of Sherman Packard for Speaker of the New Hampshire House.
Why?
Because of his vast experience, because of his proven skills and knowledge, because of his respect for all of you, and because of his respect for this great institution.
SHRM has led a lifetime of service, with over 30 years here as a representative, plus decades of service in his community and to charity organizations.
He is never boastful, because it's never about him.
For SHRM, it's always about serving you, the members, and about serving the people of New Hampshire.
In fact, I'd call his leadership style a servant leadership.
Leaders with this style serve their teams and their organization first.
They don't prioritize their own objectives or work for their own glory.
Employees and members feel their voices are actually heard under this type of leadership.
And I can tell you personally I've worked closely with Sherm over many years and it's been an absolute pleasure and an honor.
With his open-door policy Sherm Packard has made it clear that the speaker's office will be a nonpartisan office for all members.
Working together has always been at the forefront of his mind, and as we begin this new term, you will see it be the forefront of a Packard administration.
As a small business owner, SHRM has a unique perspective on how to effectively manage the day-to-day activities of this House, whether it's coordinating House sessions and calendars to dealing with personnel issues and listening to member concerns, all while making sure the legislature and its business gets done under deadline and on time.
And as we work through this past legislative term, SHRM's extensive experience, not only as House Speaker but as a representative, helped the House navigate unprecedented times.
But even through this difficulty, the legislature continued to do the work for the people of New Hampshire.
If you want a speaker who will respect you and who will always demonstrate respect for this great institution with professionalism, competence, compassion, and grace, I would ask you to join me in voting for Sherman Packard for Speaker of the New Hampshire House.
Representative Lori Sanborn seconds the nomination of Representative Sherman Packard.
The chair recognizes the member from Londonderry, Representative Sherman Packard.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Fellow House members, I accept the nomination.
We may disagree on policy approaches, but we are all united in the belief that New Hampshire is one of the best places in which to live, work, raise a family, start a business, and so much more.
As a lifelong resident of this beautiful state, I raised a beautiful family, ran a small, successful business.
Now I'm blessed with three wonderful grandchildren.
The next generation.
The next generation to stand up and preserve the ideals that make our state, our country, uniquely rugged, independent, and free.
This is why public service is important to me.
It's why I wake up every day and come to this sacred building for $125 a year.
Yes, the speaker gets an extra $25 a year.
Over the last two years, this institution has faced some unprecedented challenges.
These challenges often brought out the best in us.
I believe we have emerged a stronger institution.
The key to us being stronger today than we were in 2020 is a result of striking a balance, working together, finding solutions to problems in a manner that suits the needs of the broad spectrum of opinions in this House.
And that's what really our new challenge is for the new term.
The voters sent us here with a never-before-seen balance in partisan makeup.
And the only way we can forge ahead and be successful in this environment is by working together, building consensus among our members of both parties across a broad spectrum of members.
Over the last few weeks, I have had the opportunity to meet with Representative Wilhelm to identify areas where we agree we can build stronger relationships and processes in the House.
In fact, on Monday, we revealed a four-page document outlining some of these ideas to consider.
I'm happy to report that we already have several key areas where we reach conceptual agreement on the way we do things around here, and we can move forward on those very soon.
We also have a list of administrative items we are actively discussing and exploring paths to consensus.
I'm looking forward to continuing those discussions in the coming days and weeks to make sure we are putting our best ideas forward.
Together, Representative Wilhelm and I are working on these important issues for the House.
Whether my party has 201 or 220 or something in between, please know.
The House Speaker serves all the members of all parties, and I take that very seriously.
For those of you who have worked with me over the last two years, you know my door was always open.
Everyone had a seat at the table and I always approached each day with an open mind.
For those of you who I haven't had the chance to work with, please know that I come to this new term with that same approach, with an open door and an open mind.
We will always have disagreements on policy.
We may not see eye to eye on some processes, but I will always treat each of you with the respect and dignity and the office you hold deserves.
You represent the people of your district, and your public service gives them a voice here in the Statehouse.
It's an awesome duty and responsibility.
The famous words of Thomas Jefferson still ring true today.
In support of this declaration, with a firm reliance on the protection of divine providence, we mutually pledge to each other our lives, our fortunes, and our sacred honor.
To that respect, with the divisions and polarization we experienced as a result of not being in the same room and as each other for too long, we need to return to decorum and civility.
We need to look each other in the eye and show that respect and dignity to our fellow legislators enact in ways that honors our constituents and this great institution.
I believe with tolerance and respect we can work together, right here in this historic chamber, in our committee business, in our debates, our interactions over the course of the term.
Standing here with all of you is a reminder to how great this state is and how much we can do when we set aside our political differences.
As citizens of this state, we understand the importance of doing things our way, the New Hampshire way.
I want to close with some words from my dear friend and predecessor, Speaker Dick Hinch, which he included in the calendar notice two years ago this week.
I ask each of you not to look at each other, not as Republicans and Democrats, but as friends and colleagues, working together towards the same goal.
We have a responsibility to respect each other, work with each other, and understand each other.
We are all here to make a positive difference in our communities and our state.
We may have different ideas, but we all want to do what we believe is right, and there's nothing political or partisan about that.
Thank you.
Representative Packard accepts the nomination.
The chair being aware of no further nominations, the chair closes the nominations.
At this time, the sergeant at arms will escort all members into the chamber so that we can begin the voting process.
All members shall be escorted into the chamber for the voting process members should take their seats Gracias.
The balloting procedure will be as follows.
Those that need assistance from the chair, I will come and cast your ballot for you.
I will pick that ballot up and deliver it on your behalf.
So please indicate that when the balloting is open.
Balloting will be done by division.
When you have marked your ballot, please remain seated.
I will call each division individually.
There are two ballot boxes in the front of the chamber and two in the rear.
Number one is on your left near the chamber door and is for ATE.
Thank you.
There are two ballot boxes in the front of the chamber and two in the rear.
Number one is on your left near the chamber door and is for A to E.
Number two is in the back on the left and is for F through L.
Number three is in the back to your right and is for M through P.
Number four is on the right and in the front and that is for Q through Z.
It is important that you use the correct ballot box.
Staff members from the House Clerk's Office and the Republican and Democratic offices are stationed at each box.
Before you deposit your ballot in the box, please clearly state your name so the staff person can check you off the list, and the partisan staffer will lift up their arms so that you can cast your ballot.
For ease of traffic flow in the front and back, please do not leave your seat until your division is called, then please return to your seat via an aisle away from your division.
The ballot clerks for the election of the speaker, Box 1, A through E, from the clerk's office, Paul Bryant, from the Republican Office, Jeremy Baker.
From Box 2, from the Clerk's Office, Michael Coe, and the Republican Office, Meg Stone.
For Box 3, Teresa Preston from the Clerk's Office and Rachel Cole from the Democratic Office.
And for Box 4, Gail Middleton from the Clerk's Office and Slate Goodwin for the Democratic Office.
Each candidate has named two tellers that will be responsible for counting the ballots at the conclusion and the chair likewise appoints two tellers.
The members themselves will do the counting.
The clerk's staff will deposit the ballots on the tables.
The members who are the tellers will then separate the ballots into stacks.
We have four stacks.
Packard stack, Wilhelm stack, write-in stack, blank ballot stack.
Blank ballots that are cast do count.
A majority of ballot count cast is required for a selection of a winner.
The tellers for the election of speaker, representatives Stephen Smith and Sanborn for Packard, representatives Talersky and Adjutant for Wilhelm, and the chair appoints representatives Hunt and Schuett.
At this time, the clerk staff will distribute ballots.
Thank you.
If there are extras, please hand them back to the staff.
Ladies and gentlemen, just so you know, if we are required to take any roll call votes today for any potential motions that might come up, it will be done in the same manner as the original call of the roll this morning.
That is a verbal roll call.
So please be aware of that.
Thank you.
Thank you, Representative Mangiaputi.
Has everyone received their ballot?
Please raise your hand if you have not.
At this time, please fill out your ballots.
And if I could have the staff go to their respective boxes, please, for the next part.
Thank you.
All right, at this time, are there members that require my assistance in casting their ballot?
Okay, I will be right there.
Thank you.
Are there any other members that need assistance in casting ballots?
Last call.
All right.
At this time, Divisions 1 and Division 5, please rise and begin to cast your ballots.
All other members should remain in their seats.
Please return to your seat as soon as you have cast your ballot.
I would suggest exiting to your right to form a line and then returning via the left.
Should have said that first.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Members should remain in the chamber during the balloting process.
Thank you.
Members should return to their seats once they have cast a ballot.
With my apologies to the leadership teams seated in Division 2 and four.
I'm breaking with tradition.
Division three, you're up.
Gracias.
Thank you.
.
Ah, not to walk around on a watch.
Thank you.
Excuse me.
I stepped away.
Otherwise, you're going to need to move through here.
Yes.
I represent my life.
Thank you.
.
I can't remember where the paper count is.
I know.
Thank you.
Okay, if those who have voted can please return to their seats so we can have the next group vote, please.
If you have voted, please return to your seats.
Do not hang out in the aisles.
All right.
Just like my daughter's four-year-old recital the other night, it was organized chaos.
So I do apologize.
My plan was to have this be disorganized and not chaotic, but apparently you know what they say about good intentions.
So at this time, would Divisions 2 and 4 please cast their ballots?
Thank you.
How are you?
And you're not good to see.
Wait, did I forget what that happened?
Is that hysterically funny?
Is that a good person?
I think he should look at him with the attention and be like, hey, I'm famous.
Yeah.
What's his name again?
Yoshi's name.
Thank you.
What's his name again?
My daughter's Catholic because we're here and she's here.
And I went to visit her in like two or three weeks after she's here.
And the clown was like, I'm going to send this kids away.
She's like, no.
I used to give them a treat.
She doesn't get older.
And, but now it's like when I visit her, she's here.
She's my daughter.
Uh huh.
Oh really?
Thank you.
Oh, really?
I think it's a separate.
I got an interesting thing.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Did you change the thing?
Hi, it's good to see you, Mom.
Congratulations.
How's it going?
Oh, Mom, this is Anita Burrow.
He's on the PFAS.
Yeah.
No, that's good.
That's okay.
Oh, good, good.
Yeah.
I'm just coming out here.
All the new things I need to do, we're in the 2011, the third floor.
I just sit down.
I'm going to go to the floor.
Good, yes.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, but the way you're here, you can hardly get in.
You know, like through the door, it's really old.
But upstairs, or downstairs.
I know.
Thank you.
I haven't heard any of Russell's about, I mean, last week, I just saw a bunch of, there was a lot of people who were sending me in, and I was just really in the report that he was saying, he had the other people who were reporting to be the other people who were talking about.
Yeah, yeah, and you know, if you know, Thank you.
Members, please take your seats once you have voted.
Do not stand in the corners and chit-chat.
The faster we get through this, the faster we move on.
Thank you.
Okay, I'll let you know where.
All right.
Have all members voted?
Members, take your seats please.
Members, take your seats.
The main highway here?
I'm not, but you are.
That's why I didn't give up.
.
Staff at the ballot boxes, has everybody in your lines dissipated?
Good.
I hereby declare the ballot closed.
At this time, the ballot boxes in the rear will be brought forward.
The tellers should please come forward.
One teller for each side.
So Representative Stephen Smith over here, Representative Sanborn here, Representative Talerski here, Representative Adjutant here, Representative Hunt here, Representative Schuett here.
Just a reminder, there are no snacks permitted on the House floor.
There is water permitted on the House floor, but no snacks.
Now, here's what's going to happen.
The ballot boxes are going to be emptied onto the tables.
The tellers will look and make sure that the ballot boxes are empty.
The tellers will then sort into their respective piles.
The House will be in a brief recess while the counting happens.
That being said, if any member chooses to leave, you must go through the back.
I don't want any other members up here peering.
Thank you.
Okay.
Obrigado.
Thank you.
for those of you who are asking or are in the gallery, we will continue right through.
So following this, we have election of two House officers.
Both of those are uncontested.
We will then go into joint convention for the purposes of electing the Secretary of State and State Treasurer, and we will come out of that.
We do not anticipate breaking for lunch.
Thank you.
Obrigado.
and .
Here.
I know.
Thank you.
Gracias.
That's right.
Thank you.
The House will come to order.
Members should take their seats so I can make the announcement of results.
Thank you.
Members, please take your seats so that I can announce the results.
Members take your seats so that I may announce results please.
Thank you.
Gracias.
The House will attend to a communication.
In a communication dated December 7, 2022, Mr.
Paul Smith, Clerk of the House, Dear Paul, please be advised that the following representative-elect was sworn into office by the governor and council on this day, representing Belknap County District 4, Travis J.
O'Hara.
Representative, welcome.
Representative O'Hara did not participate in the vote as he was not sworn until after the ballots had been closed.
So, just for your information.
All right.
The House will come to order.
With 391 ballots cast, 196 were necessary for the election.
There were zero write-in votes.
There were two blank ballots cast.
Representative Matthew Wilhelm received 184 votes.
Representative Packard received 205 votes.
The representative from Londonderry is elected the Speaker of the House.
Gracias.
First of all, I want to thank everybody.
It was a tremendous honor two years ago, and it is a tremendous honor again.
I love this institution.
I still get goosebumps every time I walk through the door because obviously none of us do this for the money in this chamber.
But I've been here 32 years and it still means the world to me.
And being back here as Speaker really means the world to me.
We've got a lot of work to do over the next two years.
And as I said earlier, I firmly believe that we can do that work and get it accomplished, and we can pass a good budget, and we can pass a good capital budget, and we can get some good legislation.
Eighty-five percent of the legislation we do usually is bipartisan.
So let's get to work.
Within the next couple of weeks, everybody will have their committee assignments, their seating assignments, their parking assignments, and come January, we'll be ready to hit the ground running.
Thank you all.
Thank you again.
Thank you.
Before I recognize you, Representative, I hereby appoint Representative Osborne and Wilhelm, leaders of their respective caucuses.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I want to move that your remarks be moved to the Permanent Journal and congratulate you on your victory today.
Thank you.
The President.
Without objection, so ordered.
The House will come to order.
The House will proceed with the election of House officers.
Nominations for clerk.
Chair recognizes Representative Mooney.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and good afternoon to my colleagues in the New Hampshire House.
I rise to place the name of Paul Smith of Hopkington to the position of clerk of the New Hampshire House.
Now Paul and I go back a ways.
We were first elected as freshmen to this house in the year 2002.
I have the blue book with me at my seat from that time period.
Amazingly, if you look at our photos in the book, you'll quickly discover that we look now exactly as we did in 2002.
We haven't changed one bit, not a bit.
It's evident that to manage, advise, and direct the third largest English-speaking legislative body in the world that the following are essential.
Expertise, temperament, and accessibility.
Paul has all of these and far more.
As an expert, he's been on the State House staff since 2005 and a clerk's office since 2011.
He serves on the Mason's Manual Commission, now as its vice chair.
And he's considered by other house clerks nationwide as a foremost authority on parliamentary procedure.
His temperament has been tried and tested, especially this past legislative session, taking this legislative body on the road to UNH Sports Field, Bedford Sports Plex, and Manchester's Doubletree Hotel.
Each session run with precision and professionalism.
Paul's accessibility is around the clock with virtually unlimited access to him for a question or a clarification or whatever else a member may need.
Please continue Paul in his role of clerk by voting for his nomination.
Thank you for your attention.
You forgot to mention our infamous drive-in.
The chair recognizes a member from Hopkinton, Senator David Luno for the purpose of second and nomination.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Speaker.
And I second the nomination of my friend Paul Smith to be clerk of the New Hampshire House.
I can't really add too much to what Representative Mooney just spoke of, other than Paul gives all of us his cell phone number with the instructions to call him any time of day.
And there are times when we're working late and need to draw on his knowledge and experience, which is significant, and Paul is there for us.
So please support my friend Paul Smith to be our next clerk of the New Hampshire House.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Speaker.
Are there any further nominations?
That being none, I declare nominations closed and cast one ballot for Paul C.
Smith, declare him the duly elected clerk of the House for the 23-24 biennium Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for this honor.
As most of you know, this is my dream job.
I love this job and I can't imagine myself doing anything else but being here to serve you.
That is correct.
You have my cell phone number.
My wife who is with us in the gallery today does not always appreciate when I get calls on weekends but I do answer.
So please feel free to call me.
I would just note that yes Representative Mooney was right.
20 years ago nearly this day, I was sworn in as a member of this house, and my mom, who is with us in the gallery today, yes, that's a bingo for someone, is here again.
So very much thanks, Mom, and thanks to my wife, Jen, for their support and love, and thank you all.
I look forward to continuing to work with you.
Nominations for the position of the House Sergeant-in-Arms are in order.
The chair recognizes a member from Kingston, Representative Ken Wyler, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I don't see, there he is.
Is J.B.
here today?
Yes, he is.
I rise to nominate J.B.
Cullen for Sergeant at Arms for the 2023-2024 term.
We who were here last term can attest to his professionalism and thoroughness.
He is the quiet man who stands by the door and quietly signals to his able staff when to shut the back doors.
This man and his crew keep us safe from unauthorized people wandering into this chamber to disrupt our deliberations.
The staff are the ones who assure the latest amendment is in your seat back when they are needed.
If any one of us had an emergency, they would be the first to notice it and take appropriate action.
JB is an educated man with a master's in forestry, still teaches it a little bit part-time, but he now turns his attention to our safety and the training of a competent staff and the preparation for any emergency that might threaten our proceedings.
We are so quietly and thoroughly cared for that it is almost imperceptible.
So I ask you now to take a look at the quiet man by the door, give he and his staff a round of applause, and vote for him for Sergeant at Arms.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes the member from Concord to represent Timothy Susti for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and lucky for all of you, I'm a man of few words.
And I did tell JB today that I would be quick, and my friend from Kingston stated that nomination so eloquently that I really have nothing to add other than he is a very humble man, been here for Sergeant at Arms for four years, so I would urge you to cast that vote for J.B.
Cullen.
Thank you.
St.
Timothy Susey seconds the nomination J.B.
Cullen for the House Sergeant-at-Arms.
Are there any further nominations?
There being none, I declare the nominations closed and direct the clerk to cast one ballot for J.B.
Cullen, declare him the duly elected Sergeant-at-Arms of the House for the 2023-2024 biennium.
Thank you for selecting me as your Sergeant-at-Arms for this next term.
This will be my third term as your Sergeant at Arms.
Prior to that, I spent 11 years on the staff of the Sergeant at Arms, staffing those doors behind you.
Prior to that, I spent 35 plus years with the New Hampshire Division of Forest and Land.
I take my job very seriously.
My staff and I are responsible for your safety and secureness in this chamber, whether you be here for sessions, for our hearings, or meetings.
I ask that you help us.
If you see something, say something.
It's for your safety as well as ours.
My staff and I also will treat you with respect and dignity for the elected officials that you are.
And I would ask that you would do the same for my staff when they ask you to do something.
Thank you again for selecting me as your Sergeant of Honor.
The House will come to order.
I will now administer the oath of office to the clerk and the sergeant at arms of the House.
Raise your right hand, and where appropriate, state your name and town.
I, J.B.
Cullen, from Stratford, do solemnly swear that I will bear faith and true allegiance to the United States of America and the state of New Hampshire and will support the Constitution thereof.
So help me so help me God I J.B.
Collins do solemnly and sincerely swear do solemnly and sincerely swear and affirm that I will faithfully and impartially and affirm that I will faithfully and impartially discharge and perform discharge and perform all the duties incumbent upon me as Sergeant at Arms.
Representatives according to the best of my abilities.
Agreeable to the rules and regulations.
Of the Constitution.
The laws of the state of New Hampshire.
So help me God.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
At this point, considering that it's 1230, the clerk and I think that we still probably have a couple hours left.
There is a free luncheon downstairs put on by the Humane Society.
the Humane Society so we're going to take we're going to take a 45 minute break and come back into the chamber at 1 30 but we still do have a couple hours left thank you left.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes the clerk.
Mr.
Speaker, the Senate has organized and has elected its officers.
The President of the Senate, Senate Jeb Bradley, and the Clerk of the Senate, Tammy L.
Wright.
The House will now attend to a resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Osborne and Wilhelm offer the following.
Resolve that the House inform the Honorable Senate it has organized and is ready to meet a joint convention for the purposes of electing a Secretary of State and State Treasurer.
The question is on the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
The ayes have it.
The resolution is adopted.
Thank you.
The question is on the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay.
The ayes have it.
The resolution is adopted.
The House will attend to a Senate message.
Thank you.
.
Recognize the clerk.
Mr.
Speaker, the Senate has organized and is ready to meet with the House of Representatives in joint convention for the purpose of electing a Secretary of State and a State Treasurer.
The House will come to order.
The chair recognizes the Sergeant at arms.
The chair recognizes the Sergeant at Arms.
Mr.
Speaker, the honorable Senate.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes the sergeant at arms.
Mr.
Speaker, the honorable Senate.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Sergeant at Arms.
Mr.
Speaker, President of the Senate, the Honorable Jeb Bradley of Wolfboro.
Congratulations again.
The joint convention will come to order.
The joint convention has formed for the purpose of electing constitutional officers as Secretary of State and State Treasurer.
Nominations for the Secretary of State are now in order.
The chair recognizes the Senator from Manchester, Senator Lou D'A Sandro, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations.
Another Bishop Bradley High School graduate has risen to the heights, to the top.
Just remember that.
Good Catholic education.
That's what does it every time.
Does it every time.
Mr.
Speaker, I'm here to place in nomination the name of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
Now I'm going to be a little historian here for my colleagues.
50 years ago, I sat in seat 383 in December of 1972.
And I voted for the Secretary of State, Bob Stock.
Bob Stock was a wonderful Secretary of State and a great human being.
And he set the stage and he set the ceiling for Secretaries of State.
Bob Stock passed away as Secretary of State and was succeeded by Ed Kelly.
Ed Kelly was super.
Again, following that Max tradition of doing the right thing at the right time and being responsive to everybody, everybody, in a very non-partisan manner.
Ed Kelly was succeeded by one of my students, a Bishop Bradley High School graduate, Bill Gardner.
Bill Gardner stayed there for 40 years.
It was like a permanent job.
Never mind TDY as we do in the military.
This was permanent.
Bill Gardner.
Bill Gardner left and was succeeded by Dave Scanlon.
Dave is in the image and likeness of his precursors.
The Secretary of State has an enormous responsibility.
It's not just the election process.
It's a number of other items that have to be run efficiently and effectively.
Dave has done that.
Now, nobody's perfect.
I understand that.
I look at myself in the mirror and say, nobody's perfect.
But indeed, we all have an opportunity to do the right thing.
And Dave Scanlon has done that.
He's done that for his constituency, which is you and me.
We are his constituents.
The state of New Hampshire is his constituency.
And he's done well by his constituency.
I would hope that this body votes positively for Dave and puts him back as Secretary of State.
It's an enormously important job.
It's a job that we need to be done properly, effectively, because it's in our best interest.
It serves the people of the state of New Hampshire effectively, efficiently, and it does what we all want, the right thing.
So thank you, my colleagues.
It's been an honor and a privilege to nominate, and I indeed hope that we'll come up with the right response.
Thank you, and everybody have a great America Day.
Thank you.
Senator Lou D'Alessandro places the name of David Scanlon in the nomination for Secretary of State.
The J.R.
recognizes a member from Salem, representing Valerie McDonald for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
In front of the esteemed members of both legislative bodies, I second the nomination of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
The political process is a daunting undertaking for incumbents and newcomers alike.
Upon embarking on the term, the support is echoing through this historic chamber and down the halls of the building.
Hence freshman legislators, such as myself, are greeted with wisdom and advice.
Among the experienced faces is David Scanlon.
Under Scanlon's leadership, tens of thousands of business entities have utilized the information technology platforms made available by the Secretary of State's office.
These services continue to improve as ongoing updates increase the ease of conducting business in New Hampshire.
In addition to fueling workplace economies, Scanlon has taken much needed steps to secure voter integrity.
The previous election cycle presented seemingly insurmountable challenges That as Secretary of State, Scanlon took in stride.
His courageous administration of ballot recounts demonstrated a relentless will to protect the people's vote.
Therefore, we can be more than confident in his ability to greet the upcoming session with grace and expertise.
As I conclude this speech, I'd like to leave you with a final note.
Service.
The commitment to best serve needs to be honored every day of the session.
Today is day one.
Let's choose to be able to tell constituents that this vote, right here, right now, we got it right.
In upholding my oath of office to best serve my constituents, I cast my vote for David Scanlon, Birdsill, with the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Thank you and congratulations to our esteemed colleagues in the House.
Mr.
Speaker, I proudly rise to second the nomination of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
As a two-term House member on election law and a member and former chair of Senate Election Law Committee, I've worked closely with Secretary Scanlon and his staff.
Secretary Scanlon is a trusted, nonpartisan resource for our committees and our communities.
His team is one of the best in state government, and their work results in elections that run smoothly and have some of the highest turnouts in the country.
When our constituents go to the polls they know their votes will count.
They know they will get the results in a timely fashion and this trust in the system is what keeps our granted staters active in our democracy.
I want to emphasize the role of the Secretary of State has in protecting the first-in-the-nation primary and ensuring our constituents' voices are heard during the presidential nominating process.
The New Hampshire primary was first held in 1916 to select delegates to the Republican and Democratic National Convention.
In 1952, we held the first primary where voters directly voted for presidential candidates and the country witnessed Dwight D.
Eisenhower upset Robert Taft.
Since 1975, state law has mandated New Hampshire's primary be held at least one week prior to any similar contest and our Secretary of State has the authority to move that date to ensure we are first.
Throughout the years, many states have challenged us and through the leadership of former Secretary Gardner and Secretary Scanlon we have prevailed and held our positions each time.
They are dedicated to upholding our state law.
What makes our primary so special is that our electorate takes the job seriously in New Hampshire.
We don't fall for millions of dollars spent on advertising, the national headlines, or campaigns that operate from a consultant's headquarters.
Here the candidates actually have to earn our votes.
We expect them to shake our hands, answer our non-scripted questions, and run grassroots campaigns.
And because of this, New Hampshire is a state where all candidates have a chance.
How many times have we witnessed underdogs come away with better than expected finishes or surprise wins because they put in the sweat equity that our voters expect and I'm sure many of you here have been part of those campaigns and even though political committees DC political operatives and partisan influencers think they can diminish the granite state's voice in the presidential nomination process we have an opportunity here today to protect our first-in-the-nation status.
We can do this by electing David Scanlon to be our Secretary of State.
He has the experience and the temperament to protect our primary and ensure New Hampshire has a say in 2024 and hopefully beyond.
With decades of experience, David Scanlon has proven his ability to serve New Hampshire in a professional and nonpartisan fashion.
I hope you will join me in supporting him for our next Secretary of State.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Senator Regina Byrd still seconds the nomination of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
Chair recognizes a member of Peterborough will present Peter Leachman for purposes of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations.
Mr.
Speaker, I rise enthusiastically to second the nomination of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
I first met David in 1996 as an incoming member of the Environment and Agriculture Committee and knew David as one of the most nonpartisan members of that committee.
In my opinion, the Secretary of State is not a position you can just drop into without first, proving yourself able to assume the role of Secretary of State.
In this regard, David served as deputy for 20 years before assuming the role of Secretary of State after Bill Garner retired earlier this year.
The Secretary of State's office and the Secretary of State himself is in my opinion the most important elected position in New Hampshire due to the important oversight responsibilities, especially elections.
It is said, Mr.
Speaker, we are judged by the company we keep.
becoming Secretary of State, David has appointed two incredible people that many of us already know, Patty Lovejoy, who served on the Finance Committee with me, a Democrat, and Aaron Hennessy, that many of you know, that served on House Finance and Senate Finance, a Republican.
After David became Deputy Secretary of State, he often appeared before the House Finance Committee to testify for additional funding for election oversight, bringing the Secretary of State's office into the 21st century finally, and the need to make the Secretary of State's website a more positive experience.
Despite legislative constraints, David and his staff of 89 people have modernized all the divisions under the control of his office.
Whether as deputy or now secretary, David's goals in the Secretary of State's office have always been to streamline the process of voting and to make sure every vote counts.
Like many of us, I ventured over to the archives to observe the voting.
I asked David how it was going.
He said he couldn't be more pleased with the professionalism of his staff, the counters, or the observers.
And then he said, and it really stuck with me, because those of you who know this will certainly have heard it before, and we are going to stay here until every vote is counted.
For me, David has a proven record of being completely nonpartisan, ethical, competent, and humble.
As Deputy Secretary of State for the last 20 years before he became Secretary of State, he never took one political contribution, made one, attended a political event, or endorsed a political candidate.
We are so fortunate, Mr.
Speaker, to have David as our Secretary of State, and I hope you will join me in casting your vote for David.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Speaker.
Senator Peter Leishman seconds the nomination of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
The chair recognizes Senator from Manchester, Senator Donna Susi, for the purpose of making the nomination.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Speaker, Mr.
President.
It's my pleasure to place in nomination the name of Senator Melanie Levesque.
Senator Melanie Levesque was a colleague of mine and is an advocate and a champion and in many ways a trailblazer.
And I'm very proud to place her name before you today.
Senator Levesque has served both on the House and Senate election law committees, has done tireless work to ensure our elections are run in the most efficient, transparent, and best manner possible.
Senator Levesque chaired the Election Law and Municipal Affairs Committee in the Senate where she also advocated for important changes to ensure that every voter has the opportunity to cast their vote in each and every possible election.
But she's so many more things as well.
She's a small business owner.
She's keenly aware of the needs of businesses in our community and how businesses need to be able to interact with the Secretary of State's office.
Melanie has a plan for the office.
Melanie has a plan to modernize and to ensure impartiality and transparency.
More specifically, she will provide a template for towns for their websites so that each town website is up to date and accurate with accurate voting information.
She will expand the use of e-poll books so every community can increase efficiency at polling locations.
And she will support our local elected officials by utilizing state funding or HAVA funds, the Help America Vote Act funds, to provide grants to help recruit and train poll workers and volunteers, and ensure, once again, transparency, efficiency, and accuracy within the office.
I think many of these changes are needed, and unfortunately, my confidence has been shaken a bit recently by some of the actions of the office, including a high-ranking employee publicly endorsing a candidate, and even following a second recount, mailing a certificate of election postmarked after the second recount to the unsuccessful candidate.
I hate to have to express those concerns, but I think they're important in our considerations today.
I've worked with Melanie, as I know many of you have, over many years.
I believe Melanie will be an excellent Secretary of State.
She's a person of integrity.
She's a person willing to roll up her sleeves and do the hard work.
She's a person willing to negotiate and to compromise.
And she's a person who I believe will serve our state very well in this capacity.
For those reasons, Mr.
Speaker, Mr.
President, I'm proud to place the name of Melanie Levesque in nomination for Secretary of State.
Thank you.
Senator Donna Soucy nominates Melanie Levesque for Secretary of State.
Chair recognizes a member from Nashmore, Representative Michael O'Brien, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations to you.
Good afternoon, representatives and senators.
I am excited to be up here in front of you seconding the nomination of the gentlewoman from Brookline, the Honorable Melanie Levesque for Secretary of State.
Now, I have gotten to know Melanie during her time as state representative and as a senator representing several of our wards as part of the great city of Nashua.
It was clear to me personally and to others, the voters, that Melanie puts the needs of her constituents first.
She proved herself to be a serious and thorough person capable of working with anyone who wanted to progress the safety and security of our, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, and the administration of the Secretary of State, a deserving trend of the Secretary of supporting anti-voting policies.
Starting in 2014, with the support of a requiring 30 days residency when voting, a bill that the ACLU argued was unconstitutional.
To his support of Senate Bill 3, which multiple courts said was unconstitutional and in the process of wasting $4 million in taxpayers' funds to defend the bill.
And just last year when he supported Senate Bill 418, he himself said it would be unconstitutional, but still supported it.
In the case of Senate Bill 418, the secretary broke with his predecessor in supporting a provisional ballot system in New Hampshire.
After advocating for the bill and the right before the governor to sign it, in part with the secretary's advice, one on record is saying he hadn't noticed a section that would disenfranchise overseas active military voters Our voters deserve particularly better than that Including our military who are serving us overseas and out of state We have something that's near and dear to me in my job though People know me as on the Board of Alderman in Nashville.
We have infrastructure And I'm going to say, We have Something that's near and dear to me in my job though that people know me as on the board of Alderman in Nashville We have infrastructure and When infrastructure breaks down Its things don't work and that includes our ballot counting devices here in the state They were last manufactured in 2008 and in 2019 the company that makes these machines won they would not last very much longer.
Anyone familiar with these machine knows they are now prone to break infrequently.
These machines are running out of time and even though the warnings came over three years ago the office has failed to act until now.
This failure to act means that we now must scramble to find the right machine and hope our machines hold up long enough for the new ones to be approved.
I am confident that under the tutelage of Melanie Levesque, that the Secretary of State Office will look forward to see the problems be addressed and address them proactively and I am confident she will support legislation That will make our elections more accessible and more secure to all residents of the state of New Hampshire So I urge you to support with me as I second the nomination of the gentlewomen from Brookline, the Honorable Melanie Levesque.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Representative Michael O'Brien seconds the nomination of Melanie Levesque for Secretary of State.
Chair recognizes the member from Concord, Representative Mary Jane Walnut for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations.
Representatives and senators, good afternoon.
Today I have the honor and the pleasure of seconding the nomination for Honorable Melanie Levesque for Secretary of State.
I first met Melanie in 2006 when she was elected to this body.
In the House, I know her as an effective, passionate advocate for equality who was always well-prepared and well-informed.
Unfortunately, as happens all too often with our strong House members, after three terms, Melanie sought the extra elbow room across the wall and ran for the Senate.
In 2019, Melanie was the chair of the election law in the Senate, election law committee in the Senate, and I was the chair of the Finance Committee in the House.
The The Secure Modern Accurate Registration technology, also known as the SMART Act, which had a fiscal impact, had passed the Senate and the House Election Law Committee and was referred to the Finance Committee.
Melanie came to the Finance Committee prepared to talk about how the SMART Act would benefit granite staters in prepared to talk about how the SMART Act would benefit granite staters.
In order to make sure she had all the details correct, she went to different Secretaries of States throughout New England and talked with them all about their automated voter registration systems.
An important piece of these trips, and Melanie did not take these trips alone, she brought with her the stakeholders.
Together, local elected officials, representatives, and senators, and members of the Secretary of State's office, including then Deputy Secretary of State Scallon, so everyone who was part of the process understood the benefits and how it moved forward.
Melanie isn't running to keep the status quo, and it is important to know as she moves the office forward, she will not do it alone, but with everyone's voice being heard.
Some members sitting here today wonder why New Hampshire needs change.
I think most of us in this room would agree.
New Hampshire runs safe, secure elections and we routinely have very high voter turnout.
However, being stagnant is not an option.
We cannot miss out on the benefits of new ideas and infrastructure.
Melanie will modernize the Secretary of State's office by bringing needed transparency to the office's budget and by using technology to update the way we submit campaign finance reforms, lobbyist reports, and business filings.
We can also trust Melanie to protect the first in the nation primary.
Make no mistake, we have gone first for 100 years, and we will continue to go first.
Melanie will spend the upcoming months defending the primary and ensuring we continue to be first in the nation.
Melanie Levesque has all the tools necessary to run the Secretary of State's office and move it into the 21st century.
I am thrilled to second Melanie Levesque for a Secretary of State and hope you will join me in voting for her.
Representative Walner seconds the nomination of Melanie Levesque for Secretary of State.
Chair recognizes Senator for Portsmouth, Senator Rebecca Perkins-Kowocca for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker and Mr.
President.
And congratulations.
for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker and Mr.
President, and congratulations to all of you here in the chamber.
I rise to respectfully second the nomination of the Honorable Melanie LeVake for Secretary of State.
Melanie LeVake is a small business owner and former legislator serving in both the House and Senate.
She was chair of the Senate Election Law Committee and has been a long-time champion for voting rights, a voice for making our elections function efficiently and securely and fairly for all.
She decided to run for Secretary of State to bring this expertise to all Granite Staters.
We take pride in our first-in nation primary, and Melanie is no exception.
Our honorable colleague is also running to be a Secretary of State who will implement the modernization reforms which will expand voting rights in the office, making our elections more secure and streamlining our corporate processes for New Hampshire small businesses and their workers.
As a corporate attorney and voting right advocate, I have seen the differences between New Hampshire and other states, and it serves us all to keep this modernization effort moving forward.
Change and innovation, while hard, is a vital part of government.
As a former Portsmouth City Councilor, I know firsthand the impacts that decisions here in Concord can have on our elections and on local election officials in our communities.
As a senator, I've had the pleasure to serve on the Election Law and Municipal Affairs Committee and during this time, I've worked with Secretary Scanlon and have been able to form a personal connection with him.
But I also see from these positions I have been so fortunate to hold that we cannot continue to do things the way we have always done them.
Now at this moment in our democracy, we must be clear-eyed about building a deep confidence in our elections, which requires keeping a constant eye on the modernization that today's world requires.
Things like making sure we will have a voting machine that works for our 2024 election.
Right now, our 2008 technology may be obsolete by then.
Joining a multi-state database named ERIC, which 31 states, including governors from both sides of the aisle, have joined and which gives our local officials additional information to keep our voting rolls accurate.
Providing for safe and secure online voter registration to make our residents' lives easier.
And hopefully avoiding the confusing experience of recounts being reopened, though we all agree the winner sits here today in our chamber with all the ballots counted.
Change is now within our grasp.
Melanie has promised the reform of the that the office needs, a commitment to modernizing election results not in PDF, campaign finance reports that are easier to submit and access, and modernizing our elections to make them more accessible and secure.
Even making sure that accurate polling locations are always available to our voters on the website.
New Hampshire deserves and needs a Secretary of State who will move New Hampshire forward.
It is why I am proud today to second the nomination of Melanie Levick, and I hope you will join in voting for her.
Senator Rebecca Perkins-Colker seconds the nomination for the Secretary of State.
Are there any further nominations?
There being none, the chair declares nominations for the Secretary of State closed.
Will the Sergeant of Arms make sure all the members are in the chamber so that the clerk may read the balancing procedure.響鐘 The chair recognizes the clerk.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Balloting will be done by division, and the Senate members will cast their ballots in the A through E box to my right.
The ballots will be handed out by my staff.
When you have marked your ballot, please remain seated.
Each division will be called individually.
As a reminder, there are four ballot boxes.
Number one, A through E is on your left near the chamber door.
Number two, F through L is in the back left near the rear door.
Number three is back there.
To your right is M through P.
And number four up here is Q through Z.
Thank you.
near the rear door number three is back there to your right is m through p and number four up here is q through z it is important that you use the correct ballot box staff members from the house clerk's office and the republican and democratic offices are stationed at each box before you deposit your ballot in the box please clearly state your name so the staff person can check the list for For ease of traffic flow in the front and the back, please do not leave your seat until your division is called.
Then please return to your seat via an aisle as quickly as possible away from the division.
So the recommendation is if you exit to the right and come back to the left.
The tellers that will be counting the ballots after the ballots have closed for Ms.
Levesque I'm sorry.
and come back to the left.
The tellers that will be counting the ballots after the ballots have closed for Ms.
Levesque are Representatives Lane and Bolden.
For Mr.
Scanlon are Representatives Doucette and Senator Pearl.
And the chair on behalf of the House appoints Representatives Hunt and Schuett as the remaining tellers.
At this time, the Senate is invited, excuse me, the ballots for the Senate, because he's got that box.
He's got the ballots.
Okay.
Thank you.
If you have extra ballots, please give them back to the staff.
All right, I'll take it.
All right.
All of the Senate received a ballot?
Will the members cast your ballots, please?
And vote, obviously.
And would the staff members please go to their respective boxes.
Just a reminder, the members of the Senate are encouraged to vote please up here at the A box at this time if you have voted please with the members of the Senate please come forward and cast their ballots and also division three you are welcome to go catch your ballots Thank you.
I'm going to go over the course.
I've been here.
It's crazy.
It's a wild time.
Christmas time.
I've got one with Howard.
You and Howard excited.
Yeah.
Do we get a little stiffer?
That would be funny.
Thank you.
All right.
Obrigado.
Thank you.
I like this the first thing.
Are there other members of the House that require assistance casting a ballot?
Thank you.
We need our call.
Gracias.
I'm going to talk to you about interesting things.
And I responded, I said I need to speak up here.
I did, I was 16 to 18, and I probably talked to you.
And he just said, okay to speak up here.
I read that in 1618, and I probably talked to him.
I think he said he's a good guy.
He said he's a good guy.
He said he's a soon as you have voted and clear the aisles.
Thank you.
At this time, I would invite Division 1 and Division 4 I'm sorry.
At this time, I would invite Division 1 and Division 4 to please cast their ballots.
Thank you.
Yes.
Wrong skips.
Thank you.
Gracias.
...
Division two, if you are good to go.
Thank you.
.
Okay.
I'm going to go ahead and am still a lot of a variable.
The purple tie is clutch, by the way.
I know you got my surprise.
My suggestion of having him music music.
Thank you.
You have a surprise to Chuck.
I'm sorry.
No, we have a message.
But, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
And Division V, you're welcome to vote.
I'm surprised any Democrats I will say I'm also We can learn Thank you.
.
Once you have voted, please take your seats or go into the ante room if you need to.
Thank you.
.
Would the members please clear the aisles if you have already voted?
Thank you.
How much ham will you pay?
We'll give you an extra 50 bucks.
What's that?
Oh yeah.
Two ham.
That was good.
And a couple of the crazy ones.
Let's go out.
I'm going to take a pair of them.
You want me?
That's right.
Thank you.
Gracias.
No.
Thank you.
.
I don't know what's going on.
I've heard a lot of people are talking about.
I think a lot of people are still talking about them.
It's good being down here.
I never heard of them.
I'm sorry.
Just do it there, Andrew.
Thank you.
Gracias.
.
Have all members voted?
Mr.
Speaker.
Thank you.
Have all members voted?
Mr.
Speaker.
I declare the ballot closed.
Will the members please clear the aisleways.
The staff will bring forward the ballot boxes.
I would ask that there be no members up here, please, while we begin the counting process.
Representative Lane, if you would please come up here.
Representative Bolden to my right.
Representative Doucette over here, Senator Pearl here, Representative Schuetz over here, and Representative Hunt over here.
There, you're good.
At this time, the same proceed, will the house please come to order?
The house will come to order.
Members take your seats.
Members of the staff will deposit the ballots on the table.
Thank you.
members of the staff will deposit the ballots on the table.
The boxes will be cleared of their contents.
The tellers will sort into four piles.
Levaque, Scanlon, write in blank.
They will then count the piles, and report the same to the chair.
.
Thank you.
I can do it.
Gracias.
Thank you.
I'm going to make sure that these are .
.
Thank you.
I can't make any mistakes.
I just wondered if I can have the right standing here.
No, I was just trying to prepare.
I was just trying to discounted which one you did.
Oh, no.
I was just going to get the last time and figure out to say it again.
I just counted.
You did the cash on time.
No.
Okay.
I'm trying to keep sure that .
You don't get .
Okay, six from here.
You can't even .
Yeah, I check.
Double check.
Thank you.
Oh, God, maybe not.
No, maybe not.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay, sorry.
No, just do what you do.
Okay.
Thank you.
Aye.
Yes, that everything that you did.
Yes, and I agree.
Thank you.
I said something.
What?
Oh, please.
I've seen it in the ground.
No, I think.
I think she was ready.
I'm not sure.
I'm not.
Thank you.
Oh, I know.
I mean, you know I mean, it's really not good.
Yeah.
Okay, let me see.
I mean, my example, for you guys, this is 10.
I can't believe it.
It's good.
No, it's good.
Yeah, it's good.
Thank you.
So beautiful.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Members take your seats.
The hulls will come to water.
Thank you.
Members, take your seats.
House come to water.
There were 413 ballots cast, 207 needed for election.
Zero blank ballots, one write-in, 175 for Levesque, 237 for Scanlon.
Gracias.
Nominations for state treasurer are now in order.
The chair recognizes Senator from Manchester, Senator Lou D'Alessandro for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you Mr.
Speaker.
This is two in a row.
This is the first time in my life that I was able, I am going to be able to nominate a person with an Italo-American name.
Come on!
Let's hear it!
Monica Zempelli, as my grandmother would say, not Italian, but a nicer girl.
Okay?
And that's what she said about my wife, and it's lasted.
I'm pleased to nominate Monica Zempeli to be the New Hampshire State Treasurer.
Monica's a graduate of LaSalle University, and she's a certified public accountant.
Prior to her election as state treasurer in 2020, Monica served as deputy state treasurer for six years and has just been outstanding.
It was during this time that I worked with Monica on the New Hampshire College Tuition Savings Plan Advisory Committee.
I've also worked with her during both the operating and capital budget process, where she's been an invaluable resource to the legislature, sharing her knowledge and expertise.
This is a job that is truly, truly not recognized, not given enough credit by the legislature itself because she decides what is our capacity for bonding, what's the capacity for the capital budget, and gives us these numbers.
She manages our money.
At one time, we had $2 billion in the bank.
$2 billion.
And that money could gain interest because of the new federal law, and she did a marvelous job of handling that.
So I believe she's the only nominee.
I hope that you will give her a great Christmas present in terms of your vote and carry forward and elect Monica Mezapelli as your state treasurer.
Thanks so much and have a great day.
Senator Lou D'Alessandro nominates Monica Mezapelli for state treasurer.
Chair recognizes the representative from Kingston, Representative Ken Wyler, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, Mr.
President.
I rise to second the nomination of Monica Mezopelli for Treasurer of the State of New Hampshire.
I've known and worked with Monica for five years.
I'm also a member of the College Tuition Savings Plan Advisory Commission.
The State Treasurer has an important role there.
And she was the one even before she was the full Treasurer that was the most informed and had the best grasp of detail about what we were doing on that committee.
Treasurer's role in state government is far more complex than many realize.
As was said, the treasurer is responsible for all the borrowing to fund the government.
That involves collaborating with the bond council and other financial experts to get a credit rating.
In order to put the best light on our state to get the best interest, she creates a document called the New Hampshire information statement.
It's a great read if you want to know about the economics and the government of the state of New Hampshire.
And that's what goes to make the credit rating, can save us millions if you get a good credit rating.
So we've had a great candidate for treasurer.
She's been 20 years in state government, always dealing with finances.
She's been doing this job either as the number one or the number two person for the last eight years Please vote for Monica Mezapelli as treasurer for the state of New Hampshire.
Thank you Are there any further nominations?
There being none I declare nominations closed and direct the clerk to cast one ballot for Monica Mezapeli and declare her duly elected state treasurer for the 23-24 biennium.
The chair recognizes his secretary of state.
Thank you.
Mr.
Speaker, Mr.
President, members of the Senate and the House.
Thank you for this tremendous honor.
And thank you for what was clearly a bipartisan vote.
That was really important to me.
And I greatly appreciate it.
I would certainly like to thank Senator D'Alessandro, Representative McConnell, Senator Burtzel, and Representative Leishman for the great speeches that you gave for me today.
I really, really appreciate that.
And I would really like to thank my staff, who have worked really hard with me over the last 10 months to move the office forward and do some really great things that we all plan to continue for the next two years.
We've set a great foundation, and you're going to see some great stuff coming out of the office in the short term.
My deputies, Aaron and Patty, have been great.
And then the tremendous staff in the Secretary of State's office generally all work really, really hard, harder than any other state agency.
And I'm really, really, really proud of them.
And before I conclude my remarks, I think, you know, I do have to recognize Bill Gardner, who for the first time in 46 years is not standing at this podium.
He's left a tremendous legacy for the state of New Hampshire and our state is much better off because of his service.
Thank you very much.
The chair recognizes State Treasurer Monica Mesapelli.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Speaker, Mr.
Senate President, honorable member of this general court.
Congratulations to all of you today.
Thank you very much for your support and for your electing me as your state treasurer.
I would like to express my gratitude first to Senator D'Alessandro and Representative Weiler for nominating me today and for the very kind words.
It is a true honor to have served as your state treasurer over the last two years.
Today I'm very grateful that I get to do it again, to continue the work, to serve in this capacity, and to serve all of you and the citizens of this state.
Protecting our public funds, our taxpayer dollars, is not only my job, it really is my top priority.
I'm very honored to be here in this chamber for the first time.
Two years ago when you first elected me as your treasurer, we were at UNH and it was a time of many unknowns and uncertainties.
But we're all here again today and we're ready to do the work.
I'm certainly ready to continue the work.
There are some still experiencing some of the imbalances caused by the pandemic.
But again, I'm ready to continue the work and to do it for the citizens of this state.
I also wanna take just a few moments to recognize the people who make things happen.
The folks at the Treasury staff who are ready to, there's a whole operation behind the scenes to ensure our money is collected, our funds have dispersed timely, and it couldn't happen without them, so I just want to take a moment to recognize them before all of you today.
So thank you again very much for your support, for your trust.
I look forward to continuing collaborating with you and working with you, starting with this upcoming legislative session.
Thank you very much.
The joint convention will come to order.
I will now administer the oath of office to the Secretary of State and the State Treasurer.
Raise your right hand and, where appropriate, state your name and town.
I do solemnly swear that I will bear faith and true allegiance to the United States of America and the state of New Hampshire and will support the Constitution thereof, so help me God.
I do solemnly and sincerely swear and affirm that I will faithfully and impartially discharge and perform all of the duties incumbent upon me as according to the best of my abilities, agreeable to the rules and regulations of the Constitution and the laws of my abilities.
Agreeable to the rules and regulations Agreeable to the rules and regulations of the Constitution of the Constitution and the laws of the state of New Hampshire and the laws of the state of New Hampshire so help me God.
So help me God.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
The Senator from Londonderry, Senator Carson, and the member from Auburn, Representative Osborne, do now move the joint convention to rise.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it.
The joint convention is adjourned.
Mr.
Speaker.
It'll be fine.
Okay, hang in there.
For what members is it?
Rise to make motion yes Gracias.
The House will come to order.
For what reason does a member rise?
I rise to make a motion mr.
speaker state your motion thank you mr.
speaker I move that the house adopt house resolution six Clerk will state the motion.
Mr.
Speaker, House Resolution 6, calling for a special runoff election for representative to the general court between Chuck Grassi and David Walker.
whereas the general election in Stratford County District 8 has ultimately resulted in a tie between Chuck Grassi and David Walker and whereas this House has both the constitutional authority to settle this matter by voting to seat one of these candidates and a tradition of endorsing the concept of the election settling a tie, and whereas the House believes that the voters of that district have already indicated by their close vote that they wish to be represented in the general court by one of these individuals.
Now therefore be it resolved by the House of Representatives that this seat be declared vacant and the election be returned to the voters of Stratford County District 8 as legally constituted as of November 8th, 2022 to uphold the principle of one person, one vote, and that if the City of Rochester chooses to hold a special election to determine their choice for representatives to the General Court, the House of Representatives orders that the ballots used in that runoff election contain only the names of Chuck Grassi and David Walker with no blank appearing, and that the Clerk of the House transmit a copy of this resolution to the Secretary of State, Chuck Grassi and David Walker, and that all communications to the Clerk of the House from the parties at interest in this matter be entered in the house journal mr.
speaker for what reason does the member rise I rise to make a motion I would like to table house resolution six that motion is in order A division will be done by standing votes.
A division will be done by standing votes.
Members, take your seats.
This will be a division vote by standing.
Representative Wilhelm has requested a roll call.
Is that sufficiently seconded?
It is sufficiently seconded.
This will be a roll call vote.
Members will take their seats.
Members should understand that once the roll call starts, this is a verbal roll call.
Members must remain in their seats for the entirety of a roll call vote.
Chair recognizes Representative Berry for a parliamentary inquiry.
He...
Are you doing it?
Yeah.
Sorry, Mr.
Speaker, I was out of courtesy.
I wanted to see if we were going to do this or not.
Our fellow members, we all knew this vote was coming today.
If I know, excuse me, I apologize.
If I know, I'm new to this, right?
If I know that the voters of Rochester deserve to have a Christmas and New Year's off, and if I know, Mr.
Speaker, that this debate that we can have can wait until the next time we meet, and it not change anything would I now vote yes on the tabling motion chair recognize the representative Wilhelm for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr.
speaker mr.
speaker if I know this body has a long-standing precedent of respecting the will of the voters in settling tied house races.
If I do not live in Rochester Ward 4 and believe it is up to the people of Rochester Ward 4, not us, to determine who represents them, if I want to begin this term in the bipartisan environment that we have all spoke so highly of today, would I now vote no on the tabling motion.
The motion before us is a tabling motion on House Resolution 6.
This is a roll call vote.
Clerk will call the roll.
Again this will be done by County and alphabetical, beginning with Belknap County.
Bean.
Yes.
Bodwin.
Bogert.
Yes.
Boards.
Coker.
No.
Comtois.
Yes.
Dume.
No.
Harvey Bolia.
Yes.
Hewitt.
No.
Thank you.
Comtois.
Yes.
Dume.
No.
Harvey Beaulieu.
Yes.
Hewitt.
No.
McCarter.
Yes.
Nagel.
O'Hara.
Yes.
Ploge, Smart, St.
Clair Terry Trottier Varney Varney Carroll County Avalcher, Brown, Bucco, Burroughs, Cordelli, Costable, Crawford, McDonald.
McAleer.
McConkie.
Paige.
No.
McAleer McConkie page Pedernal Smith Woodcock Cheshire County Abbott, Ames, Eaton, Faulkner Filio Fox Germana Harvey Hunt Jones Montiel Newell Nutting Nutting.
Partial.
Qualley.
Rhodes.
Santanastasso.
Shapiro.
Tetro.
Baxton.
Toll.
No.
Weber.
Coosk County.
Cascadden.
No.
Davis.
Yes.
Hatch.
Kelly.
No.
King.
Yes.
Myrner.
Noel.
No.
Ouellette.
Yes.
Kelly King Murner Noel will let Tierney Grafton County adjutant all me Baldwin, Berejni.
Bolton.
No.
Brown.
Yes.
Corman.
No.
Koulon.
Yes.
Fellows.
No.
Greeson.
Yes.
Hawken Phillips.
Hoyt.
No.
Ladd.ett, Massimilla, Morse, Muirhead, Murphy, Nordgren, Rochefort Sellers Simon Simon Rochefort Sellers Simon Simon Stavis stringham stringham Sullivan Sykes Hillsborough County.
Hebert.
Yes.
Alexander.
Ammon.
Yes.
Baruti.
Hillsborough County.
Hebert.
Yes.
Alexander.
Ammon.
Yes.
Baruti.
No.
Woollier.
Berry.
Yes.
Boehm.
Bouros.
No.
Bouchard.
Bolden.
No.
Boyd.
Aye.
Bradley.
No.
Thank you.
Bouchard, Bolden, Boyd, Bradley, Calabro, Kretion.
Colcom.
Cole.
Corcoran.
Cornell.
Cody.
Creighton.
Cushman, Darby, Davis, Devine, De Silvestro, Dolan, William Dolan.
No.
Dutsey.
Elberger.
No.
Erf.
Yes.
Fadolfi.
No.
Fadolfi?
Ford.
Fox.
Freitas.
Gagney.
Goalie.
Gorski.
Gould.
Greg.
Griffin.
Grill.
No.
Griffin.
Yes.
Grill.
No.
Hemmer.
Harry Gathright.
No.
Healy.
Yes.
Heath.
No.
Herbert.
Howard.
No.
Hines.
Yes.
Infantine.
Jack.
Judy.
Juris.
Kelly.
Kennedy.
Kenny.
King.
Kofalt.
Lanza.
Lascellus.
Lawton.
Leapley.
Leclerc.
Leishman.
Alicia Lekas.
Tony Tony Leckes Lewicki Lloyd Long McKenzie Manjaputi, Mannion, Missouri, McGee, McHugh, McLean, Ming, Mooney, Morton, Moulton, Murphy, Alessandra Murray.
No.
Megan Murray.
Ray Newman.
No.
Sue Newman.
Noble.
Yes.
Nutter.
Nutter Upham.
No.
Nutting Wong.
O'Brien.
No.
Panic.
Yes.
Wong.
No.
O'Brien.
Panic.
Yes.
Power.
Peterson.
No.
Perez.
Patrigno.
No.
Plett.
Yes, Mr.
Plurt.
Post.
Yes.
Priest.
No.
Prue.
Yes.
Prout, Raymond, Reed, Renzullo, Rombo, Rung, Ryan, Sanborn, Yes.
Seibert.
No.
Seidel.
Yes.
Sheehan.
Searway.
Yes.
Juliet Smith.
Sophokitis.
No.
Spear.
Staub.ub, Talerski, Ties, Tenzar, Thomas, Ulery, Vail, Veyu, Wheeler Wary Wilhelm no vayu no wheeler no wary yes wilhelm no merrimack county andrews oars aleward yes boyd brennan cambrills yes caplan no carrie yes evil Brennan.
No.
Cambrils.
Yes.
Kaplan.
No.
Carrie.
Ebel.
No.
Ellison.
Gallagher.
No.
Gerhard.
Yeah.
Gibbs.
No.
Gould.
Hall.
No.
Hicks.
Hill.
Yes.
Hole.
Lane.
No.
Levitt.
Yes.
Luno.
No.
McKay.
Mason.
Yes.
Carol McGuire.
Dan McGuire.
Yes.
Mick Williams.
No.
Moffitt.
Michael Moffitt.
No.
Myler.
Payor.
Stephanie Payor.
No.
Palazov.
Yes.
Richards.
No.
Palaozov.
Yes.
Richards.
No.
Reisner.
Schamberg.
No.
Schuett.
Schultz.
No.
Seaworth.
Yes.
See.
Shurtleff.
walsh wolf i'm sorry thank you wood Wood.
Rockingham County.
Balboni.
Ball.
Wood?
Yes.
Rockingham County.
Balboni?
No.
Ball?
Yes.
Bartlett?
No.
Bernardi?
Yes.
Brouillard?
Cahill?
Excuse me.
Michael Cahill?
No.
Timothy Cahill?
Yes.
DeSimone?
DiLorenzo?
No.
Dol, Dolan, Donnelly, Doucette, Drago, Dunn, Edgar, Edgar, Edwards, Emrick, Foote.
Ford.
Gilman.
Grossman.
Grota.
Guthrie.
Hamblett.
Harb.
Harley.
Haskins.
Nobson.
Janvron.
Katsokores.
Kahn.
Nab.
Kutab.
Leon.
Yes.
Love.
Lundgren.
Lynn.
Yes.
McDonald.
Maggiore.
No.
Malloy.
Mannion.
Yes.
Mannos.
No.
Macbeth.
Yes.
McDonald.
McMahon.
Melvin.
Muse.
Muse?
Mills.
Munns.
Murray.
Yes.
Munns.
No.
Murray.
Nelson.
Yes.
O'Neill.
No.
Osborne.
Yes.
Page.
No.
Mark Pearson.
Yes.
Steven Pearson.
Perez.
Christine Perez.
Phillips.
Piamonte.
Popovici-Muller.
Porcelli.
Patucic.
Not necessary, Representative.
Pratt.
Yes.
Prudhomme O'Brien.
Coratiello.
Yes.
Reynolds.
No.
Reed.
Roy.
Yes.
Simpson.
No.
Soti.
Yes.
Spillane.
Summers., Summers, Sweeney, Sightech, Thomas, Trip, True, Tudor, Tudor, Terer.
No.
Vallone.
Vandica Steele.
Yes.
Verveille.
Vaught.
No.
Vose.
Wallace.
Yes.
Walsh ward weiler yokella strafford county anchorburg bailey bay bickford.
Bixby.
No.
Burnham.
Yes.
Cannon.
No.
Conlon.
Connor.
Yes.
Fitzpatrick.
No.
Granger.
Yes.
Harrington.
Horrigan.
Yes.
No.
Howard.
Thank you.
Harrington.
Horrigan.
Howard.
Howland.
Kaczynski.
Kenny.
Cam Kenny.
Lamontang.
Levesque.
Minear.
Lamontang, Levesque, Muneer, Newton, Peir, Finney, Petrie, Potenza Potenza.
Yes.
Cecilia Rich.
No.
Jeffrey Rich.
Schmidt.
No.
Selig.
Jeff Smith.
No.
Marjorie Smith.
Southworth.
No.
Trelevin.
Turcotte.
Yes.
Vincent.
Wall.
Wall?
No.
Thank you.
Sullivan County.
Aaron.
Yes.
Cloutier.
No.
Dry, Merchant, Palmer, Rollins, Smith, Spillsbury, Stapleton.
Yes.
Stone.
Stone?
Yes.
Thank you.
Sullivan.
No.
Tanner.
yes stone stone yes thank you sullivan no tanner no Just think this is how they used to do it not too long ago.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Yeah.
Thank you.
.
Gracias.
I also come to order.
The vote was 187 yeas, 193 nays.
The motion fails.
House will be in order.
Chair recognizes Representative Wilhelm.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I had not planned to speak to this resolution today, but given some recent conversation about taking a different course of action, I feel like it's really important to explain why this resolution has been introduced and why it's imperative that this House votes to adopt it.
The New Hampshire Constitution affords the full House the power to seat its members, and when House races end in a tie, our collective power is called upon.
It does not happen often, but tied elections do occur in House races, and the House has a long-established precedent that respects the will of the voters.
This resolution, H.R.
6, continues that tradition of respecting the wishes of voters by returning the results to Rochester Ward 4 to decide that seat through a runoff election.
In 2014, the House clerk at the time produced a memo for the Democratic and Republican leaders explaining how the House had handled tied elections in the past.
In every instance, the House had either chosen to call a special election or split the vote between the two members.
In no instance has the House voted to simply seat one of the two members against the district's wishes.
As the clerk wrote in 2014, the House has been unwilling to intrude upon the wishes of the voters in any particular instance such as this.
The resolution before us is the only appropriate way to handle the election in Rochester Ward 4.
Any attempt by us to determine Rochester's representation without further input from Rochester's voters would be an unprecedented intrusion into voters' wishes and a horrible look for the fairness of this body.
Please join me in voting yes to adopt House Resolution 6.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Chair recognizes Representative Osborne.
Well, thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I apologize for the confusion here.
This is our first day back, and we've got a lot of kinks to work out and stuff.
So this was intended to be a joint motion, and I would encourage all of you to vote in favor of it, and hopefully we can just do a voice vote and be done.
And this is the right thing to do.
Thank you very much.
The question is on the adoption of the House Resolution 6.
Roll call.
Roll call has been withdrawn.
The question before us is the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay.
The ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
House will be in order.
We're on next to the regular resolutions that we have to do for housekeeping purposes.
The clerk will read resolution number one.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Osborne and Wilhelm will offer the following.
Resolve that the House adopt the rules of the 2022 session for the 2023-2024 biennium.
The question is on the adoption of the resolution.
ready for the question all those in favor say aye Those opposed nay the eyes have it and the resolution is adopted the clerk will read resolution number two Mr..
Speaker representative Osborne and Wilhelm offer the following resolve that all action taken at all sessions of the house Be recorded through the public address system and the recording be used by the clerk to confirm and correct the permanent journal.
The permanent journal, as prepared by the clerk and as may be corrected by the House, shall be the official record of the House.
The question is on the adoption of resolution number two.
While you're ready for the question, all those in favor say aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
The clerk will read resolution number three.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Osborne and Wilhelm offer the following resolve, that the following policy be established for the distribution of House calendars and journals, bills, and resolutions to members of the general court and state departments.
One, every citizen is entitled, free of charge, to one copy of any publication at the legislative counter, or to have the publication mailed to that person upon individual request for one such copy.
Two, persons requesting copies for the entire session will be charged with fees sufficient to cover postage, envelopes, and handling.
Such fees may be prorated when services receive proportions of the session only.
All fees are payable in advance.
The subscriber list may be submitted for legislative accounting and auditing purpose, but is not for publication or sale.
Three, all fees charged for publications in accordance with this resolution shall be fixed with the approval of the Speaker paid into the State Treasury and credited to the legislative appropriation.
The question is on the adoption of resolution number three.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
The Clerk will read resolution number four.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Osborne and Wilhelm offer the following, resolved that the Speaker may employ such personnel as he may deem necessary and with the approval of the House Subcommittee on the Committee of Legislative Facilities may fix their compensation in accordance with RSA 17-E colon five.
The question is on the adoption of resolution number four.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it, and the resolution is adopted.
Clerk will read Resolution Number 5.
Mr.
Speaker, the most important House resolution, Representative Osborne and Wilhelm, off of the fall, resolve that members will be paid their legislative salary as provided in the Constitution in the month of January, and that mileage of members of the House of Representatives be paid every two weeks during the session.
The question is on the adoption of Resolution No.
5.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
The chair recognizes the member from Auburn, Representative Osborne, for the third reading motion.
Thank you.
A resolve that the House now adjourned from the early session, that the business of the late session be in order at the present time, that the reading of resolutions be by caption only, and that all resolutions be read a third time and passed when the House adjourns today, it be convene on Wednesday, January 4th, 2023.
Question is on the third reading motion.
I'm ready for the question.
All those in favor say aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it and the motion is adopted.
The House will attend to announcements.
Chair recognizes Representative Sheward.
Is this for announcement?
Yes.
For announcement, yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
As chair of the Merrimack County delegation, I'm reminding all members who were elected for Merrimack County that our organization meeting is next Monday at 10 a.m.
at the old courthouse right here in Concord on Union Street.
Also for new members, orientation will be tomorrow from 9 a.m.
to 11 a.m.
or Friday from 1 to 3.
Hope you can all make it.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Representative Hunt for an announcement.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I'm sure you all read your calendars cover to cover, so the last paragraph.
It's back.
Sheen and Finney Capital Group cordially invites all House members and staff to their annual welcome back reception today, right now.
It's after three o'clock, so hopefully the senators haven't eaten all the food.
So please come on over across the street to Tandy's and let's celebrate this wonderful first day.
Chair recognizes the clerk.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I have several announcements on behalf of the Democratic leader.
There will be a Democratic caucus immediately following the session.
So all members that are not Democrats should please leave the chamber.
And those Democratic members should remain in the chamber.
The staff will clear out as quickly as possible, but you all should exit orderly, please.
A couple of other things.
Mileage.
If you have not signed in for mileage for today, please do sign in for mileage.
You can do that in the ante room.
You can do that up in the Speaker's office or across the street in the legislative office building behind that wall are your mailboxes they are arranged this way not this way that being said your patents of office are in your mailboxes if you have not already received them we encourage you to pick them up please do not leave any trash in the chamber following this session today.
If you left tissues in your slots, please take them with you.
Do not leave them here for when we are back in a month.
Speaking of being back in a month, we are going to meet on Wednesday, January 4th.
That is a constitutionally mandated convening day.
We will take up any amendments to House rules and introduce most pieces of legislation the following day not tomorrow the following day is the governor's inaugural if it is a joint session of the general court but no votes will be taken so if you do not wish to be present and would like to give up your seat because we have a lot of seats to give away, please do let me know as soon as possible.
Thank you.
May I ask you a question?
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
So the question of the clerk, the name tags in the mailboxes are not affixed.
They are only sitting in the holders.
And so a number of them have blown out or gotten knocked out by people.
And so when will you have them permanently attached so we can actually find our mailboxes, which I and others were unable to do today?
It will be taken care of, Representative.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
The House will attend to unanimous consent.
Representative Terleski.
If the members from Nashua who served with the Honorable Skip Cleaver, if they'd like to come up and join me for a minute.
Thank you.
with the Honorable Skip Cleaver if they'd on Thursday.
Thornton Cleaver was born in Pennsylvania in September of 1944.
His father, a Navy man, referred to his new baby as our little skipper, and for 78 years, he was Skip to all that knew him.
Skip grew up in Pennsylvania and attended the University of Maryland on a football scholarship where he also wrestled.
Before finishing his studies at Maryland, he joined the United States Marine Corps where he proudly served from 1965 to 1971.
After his service, he completed his education at Riviere College with a degree in political science and history and a master's degree in business.
Skip worked as an air traffic controller with the FAA for many years before joining the Nashua Corporation.
Over the course of his working life he taught high school and special education, was an adjunct professor at Southern New Hampshire University and Franklin Pierce, wrote a weekly column about running in the Nashua Telegraph and was the managing editor of an online running magazine.
When he retired in 2016, he ran for this New Hampshire house to represent Nashua's Ward 8, and he served three terms.
While a quiet and gentle person, Skip was a fierce advocate for social and economic justice and stood firmly for what he believed to be right, even if it was unpopular with others or not considered politically savvy.
As a member of House Transportation, he advocated for public safety, filing bills that would require the use of seatbelts and the wearing of helmets, and he co-sponsored a bill that prohibited smoking in vehicles when children were present.
Skip did not mind being unpopular, and he filed these very difficult bills because he believed it was the right thing to do.
More than once in committee, we would all come to a consensus or an agreement on an issue, and Skip would surprise all of us, being the lone vote in the minority, because he was never afraid to stand alone on an issue and Skip would surprise all of us being the lone vote in the minority because he was never afraid to stand alone on an issue.
Skip also served locally on the City of Nashua Board of Aldermen representing Ward 8 from 2019 to 2021, helping get our city through the challenging early years of the pandemic.
He was active and engaged with the Nashua Democratic City Committee and was a unifying leader when we needed him the most.
Under his leadership as chair of the committee, Democrats swept the 2017 municipal election as well as the 2018 state election, winning all 27 state rep seats, two Senate seats, and the Executive Council seat.
My last conversation with him was the day after the election when he called to celebrate the 27 state rep seats again.
Many of us knew him as a slight man who moved carefully and deliberately in the last few years, but Skip was an athlete his entire life, and running was his true love, not only for the activity itself, but for the community it created.
He was a long-distance runner and completed 43 marathons.
Racing into his 70s, he successfully completed 134 mountain races, including 27 straight up Mount Washington to the summit.
He brought his love of running to the community and was a charter member of the Gate City Striders Running Club, serving as its president and eventually inducted into their Hall of Fame.
Organizing and volunteering for charity races, as well as bringing couch to 5K programs to the Nashua area, Skip took his love of running and used his connections in the community to help others.
He enjoyed a cold beer and he loved ice cream.
In March of 2020, Skip asked me to join him to get ice cream sundaes for lunch.
Having packed my lunch that day, I gave him a rain check and it was agreed that our next session day, we were on for sundaes.
We had no idea that day would be his last lunch here in Concord.
Skip will be remembered for his bright smile, the twinkle in his eyes, and his caring and giving heart.
Representative Manjapudi and I were lucky to have spent so many hours with him during campaigns listening to his stories.
He was a gentleman and a very good friend.
I hope you can join me in keeping Skip's four children, Richard, Aaron, Leslie, and Tracy, as well as his six grandchildren, in your thoughts and prayers in the coming days.
Thank you, Representative Cleaver, for your service to our country, to our state, and to our city.
You will be missed more than you know.
Can we all stand for a moment of silence for our former colleague skip cleaver Without objection, the remarks will be printed in the permanent journal.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Thank you.
I just wanted to make a quick comment about Skip Cleaver, our representative.
Chair recognizes Representative Shewitt for unanimous consent.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I'm sure you're all aware of the significance of this date, the 81st anniversary of the attack on Pearl Harbor, presaging our entry into World War II.
In remembering that...
the 81st anniversary of the attack on Pearl Harbor, presaging our entry into World War II.
In remembering that event, I would like to share an experience I had in 2016.
I took a trip to Hawaii with some old friends, the Harness family from my old neighborhood in Southern California.
Like my own late father, I knew that Bob, their father, was a veteran of the war, but also like my dad, he didn't talk about it much with his kids, and certainly not with us neighbor kids.
So in October of 2016, it was my great honor to accompany this member of the greatest generation, along with his wife and daughter, on his first visit to the Arizona Memorial.
As we boarded the memorial, Bob paused to salute his mates, over 1,100 of whom are still entombed in their ship.
He was quiet for a while, taking in the rusting hulk and the awesomeness of the gleaming white memorial that straddles it.
We slowly made our way to the diagrams of the ship below, and one of the Park Service guides, noticing Bob's World War II cap, asked about his service.
Bob told him that he had served in the Navy, in the Pacific, and described his destroyer, the Blue, and some of the action they had seen.
Several other visitors gathered around by this time, listening to his memories.
Bob said they had tied up in Pearl during the war and he knew that the Arizona was still submerged there but of course no one could visit it then and he couldn't make out for sure just where in the harbor his ship would have birthed.
The Park Service Guide smiled a little and explained that of course the area had changed quite a bit in the 70 plus years since the war.
Thank you.
The Park Service Guide smiled a little and explained that, of course, the area had changed quite a bit in the 70-plus years since the war.
He then told Bob to go over to a particular pillar at the side of the memorial and to look behind it.
He said there's a rusted piece of the superstructure of the Arizona protruding there, and he invited Bob to touch it.
Leads to say it was an emotional moment.
Many of you may know that the USS Missouri, the big Moe, on whose decks the final surrender papers of World War II were signed, is now moored at Ford's Island, just behind and visible from the Arizona Memorial.
Thank you.
of World War II were signed is now moored at Ford's Island, just behind and visible from the Arizona Memorial.
So visitors witnessed the beginning and the end of our involvement in that war, and I'm sure that somehow the crew of the Arizona know that their sacrifice was not in vain.
That was my fourth trip to the Arizona Memorial, but it's definitely the one I will never forget.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes Maria Perez, unanimous consent.
Thank you Mr.
Speaker and members.
Today I raise to give my thoughts and praise to the Peruvian community here in New Hampshire and around the world.
Today, the president of Peru dissolved the Congress.
I have relatives and friends in Peru.
The whole country is in lockdown right now.
The airport and everything is shut down right now.
And my thoughts and praise are with everyone from the Peruvian community right now.
The airport and everything is shut down right now and my thoughts and prayers are with everyone from the Peruvian community right now.
Hopefully they found peace.
Hopefully this issue is resolved as soon as possible and that's all I want to say.
Hopefully everyone can keep the Peruvian community in Utah's and prayers today.
Thank you.
More reasoning, Member Rice.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
On this Pearl Harbor Day, I would move that the remarks of Representative Shewitt, her touching testimony before this body, be placed in the permanent journal.
Without objection.
The organizational session of 23-24 House of Representatives is adjourned.